the desert is still the night seems
endless silent and at peace until it's
pierced by the sound of gunshots and
screams
deep in the Sahara the s IE Foundation
is Waging War against a newly discovered
enemy a squad of foundation agents is
retreating trying to get away from the
ones who massacred their allies
they were attempting to eliminate the
threat using conventional means but
their rifles were no match for the
reality-bending entities of the kingdom
of Abaddon the retreating agents cover
one another as they make their way back
to the extraction point the enemy Force
advances agents that are caught too
close to the Sorcerers of Abaddon
disintegrate Into Thin Air this is not
an enemy they can defeat the SCP agents
need to get back to base and relay what
they have found to their superiors
out of the hundreds of Agents sent into
the Sahara that night only a handful
make it out alive they are debriefed by
their superiors at the foundation who
classified the anomalous humanoids under
the highest of threat levels the kingdom
of Abaddon is a threat the kingdom of
Abaddon must be a limit
reconnaissance done prior to the
disastrous Mission had alerted the
foundation to the presence of anomalies
in the region but they had no idea how
strong the anomalous humanoids would be
from data gathered through old reports
it seemed like the Abaddon humanoids
were responsible for the deaths of no
fewer than 75 Foundation personnel and
had stolen at least 12 different items
from the foundation the leaders of the
SCP Foundation tasked research team
omega-5 with developing a weapon that
would be capable of destroying the
kingdom of Abaddon once and for all the
weapon they are researching must be
capable of long-range destruction
because the moment any foundation agent
gets close to the area they are
vaporized by the reality manipulating
powers of its inhabitants the project is
given the name twins of God and is led
by a foundation doctor known only by the
designation
051 o51 is popular in the SCP Foundation
well known for his in-depth research and
charismatic personality making him the
perfect person to lead such a project
and over 5-1 recently came across an
anomaly that he believes holds the
solution the foundation has been looking
for to defeat the kingdom of Abaddon
item 001
so the omega-5 team gets to work they
discover that the anomaly has incredible
Powers when put inside a host which they
refer to as an item 001 entity and set
up a series of experiments using
different people to harness its energy
the first series of tests all end in
tragedy the anomaly causes the entity it
inhabits to become intensely radioactive
anyone who gets close to it succumbs to
immediate radiation sickness and
eventually death to stop the radiation
problems the omega-5 research group
intensifies the containment procedures
o51 receives reports from the higher-ups
that the kingdom of Abaddon has attacked
another Foundation facility in Sudan
long-range defense is needed ASAP the
administrator puts more pressure on
omega-5 and especially its leader 051 to
solve the problems of item 001 and
develop a weapon that can save the
foundation he stays awake for days on
end working tirelessly to create a safe
and controllable item 001 entity
although there are signs that the weapon
will work it is still unpredictable when
item 001 is initiated the host entity
becomes paralyzed suffers severe
cerebral hemorrhaging and soon a new
host is needed before testing Can Begin
Again and that's not the only thing that
goes wrong
whenever the anomaly is put into a new
host sudden and random destruction of
on-site structures and Personnel take
place o51 knows though that if this
power can be harnessed and controlled in
the right way that it could be the
weapon that the foundation needs to wipe
out the kingdom of Abaddon once and for
all in order to control item 001 o51 has
a mind kill switch implanted in its
host's brains o51 can activate the
implant to incapacitate its host and
immediately Stop The Unwanted
destruction countless hosts are
terminated by this mine kill switch in
the early trials conducted by the
omega-5 team but progress continues to
be made and eventually a hypothesis is
formulated perhaps the disastrous side
effects of item 001 can be offset by
spreading the anomaly across multiple
subjects they theorize that the immense
mental load of the anomaly can be
distributed among several hosts thus
reducing the toil it takes on each and
giving them the ability to control its
immense power but o51 and the omega-5
team need more data and for that they
need more bodies they consult with the
director of site 17 and it is concluded
that the nearby town of San Marco would
be an appropriate place to get the
additional test subjects they require on
a quiet Sunday morning
omega-5 along with support from a squad
of armed SCP agents Storm Into the San
Marcos de la Vida sterna Church during
the middle of mass they gather up a
number of the younger congregants and
bring them back to the site where item
001 is housed the researchers quickly
ran through their new supply of test
subjects though and omega-5 would need
to get even more if their research was
to continue
instead of going back and forth between
the testing facility and San Marcos 051
decided to move the entire item 001
operation to the town itself he renames
the town testing site 001 and omega-5
rounds up 23 of the healthiest subjects
they can find for use in the next series
of research tests a few weeks after
occupying the town of San Marco
omega-5 makes its most substantial
progress yet just as they theorized by
spreading out the anomaly of item 001
across a specific group of hosts that
can control its powers the test may have
cost the lives of almost everyone in the
town
but the ends certainly justify the means
the kingdom of Abaddon poses an
existential threat to the SCP Foundation
after all and thanks to This research
they will soon have a weapon capable of
bringing them Victory the foundation
administer criticized o51's methods but
can't argue with his results
unfortunately 051 has a dark secret as
secret that disturbs even the most
hardened and loyal members of omega-5 a
secret that has to do with the item 001
hosts the host that omega-5 has made its
major progress with are not the ordinary
test subjects normally used by the
foundation no the test subjects 051
makes his breakthrough with are children
nine of them to be exact all between 4
and 11 years old despite being told
specifically by the foundation
administrator to only test on adults the
research required 051 to break the chain
of command and follow the science down
the path of lead the children are
contained in a reinforced bunker where
only 051 and a select few have access
they are technically alive but are
functionally brain dead the group of
nine children share a hive mind that can
process information and more importantly
can unleash the full potential of the
implanted anomaly creating and
controlling a devastating power but not
everyone is thrilled with what they've
achieved members of omega-5 are haunted
by the screens of the children that they
force to be part of their weapons
development program they describe their
merging with item 001 as being a process
that rips out their souls and replaces
them with something much more Sinister
in fact all of omega-5 regret what they
have been a part of and they've done all
except 051 the nine children can Channel
unprecedented amounts of energy from an
unknown origin that omega-5 hypothesizes
comes from an extra dimensional source
which is used to unbind atoms at the
quantum level when the right activation
words are spoken it appears as though
this tremendous power gives the children
the ability to annihilate anything in
the entire universe it's a gun to end
all guns and only o51 has the key to
control it the nine children work so
well with an item 001 that omega-5
reclassifies it to include the nine
children themselves they are not just
the entity housing or controlling item
001 they permanently become item 001
once omega-5 has a better understanding
of item 001 they begin to run tests to
find out the full extent of its
abilities first they test the distance
item 001 can reach the initial test that
Omega 5 carries out is on a steel rod
placed five kilometers away 051 orders
the children to destroy the target
moments later the phone next to o51
begins to ring when he picks it up the
Observer tasked with washing the pole is
on the other end he informs051 that the
steel rod has been completely vaporized
o51 is not satisfied though he has
another pole sent out this time placed 8
000 kilometers away from the nine
children 051 asked the children to
destroy that Rod almost immediately the
phone rings again the target has been
vaporized
oh five one Smiles the next series of
tests omega-5 runs on item 001 are to
determine the maximum size of an object
that can be destroyed the tests start
out with a steel sphere 3 meters in
diameter placed one thousand kilometers
from item 001 051 orders the children to
destroy the object it is instantly
vaporized 051 has seen enough small
tests it time for something big so he
does something that will later be
questioned by everyone at the SCP
Foundation he orders the nine children
to destroy a church of the broken God
worship site in Turkey not long after
the destruction order is given to item
001 reports begin coming in the worship
site has been obliterated with no
observable damage to the surrounding
area deadly and precise 051 closes his
eyes and takes a deep breath he looks as
if he's overcome by an immense spiritual
experience he opens his eyes leans over
to the children and Whispers the name of
someone later that day 051 finds out
that the target he had named has been
vaporized the success of omega-5 in item
001 is relayed to the administration of
the foundation they are so impressed
that they make plans to use item 001 to
eliminate the Abaddon threat once and
for all however one of the heads of the
foundation administrator Williams has
major concerns about the way o51 is
running the program the updates that o51
has been sending have become less
scientific
philosophical
more spiritual administrator William
sends a letter to 051 reassuring him
that he is doing good work but once the
mission to destroy the kingdom of avadon
is completed o51 will be promoted to
director and reassigned to the newly
constructed site 19 for the good of the
foundation and maybe the rest of the
world
will be permanently moved away from item
001 o51's response is short and to the
point
I am fine administrator the project is
finished we will complete our task when
you arrive
administrator Williams arrives at
site-001 a few days later he is greeted
by 051 and the omega-5 team Williams
can't help but notice that 051 has a
strange look in his eyes it is the look
of a crazed man who has been lost in his
work and who has perhaps lost himself
Williams puts the thought away though
and walks with 051 and his accompanying
agents to the viewing area where the
powers of item 001 will be demonstrated
administrator Williams and the other
agents watch from a protected viewing
room as 051 enters the Chamber of his
new super weapon it's time to see if
their weapon that has had so much time
effort sweat tears and especially blood
poured into it will have been worth it
everyone watches as 051 leans over and
says the name of the Abaddon Citadel to
the nine children all at once they start
to Glow no one observing can see what
has happened in the far-off Kingdom but
they know something big has happened the
administrator is thrilled but notices
something
051 hesitated the moment while leaning
over the children before standing back
up did he whisper something else to them
and then administrator Williams
vaporizes pulled apart at an atomic
level before he has the chance to scream
what's going on the agent standing next
to where administrator Williams
previously existed began to yell and
pull out their guns they burst through
the door of the observation room and run
down the hallway towards where 051 and
the nine children are located the arm
agents rush into the room but 051 is
gone
nine children are still
over the next few weeks 051 is reported
to be seen several times by SCP agents
however no one is able to catch him and
it appears as though other members of
the SCP Foundation have also gone AWOL
as well perhaps joining him on the run
it is unclear what his plan is but the
reports from the reconnaissance team
sent into the Sahara make it obvious
what the result of his first command to
the children was there isn't a single
humanoid or building left in the Kingdom
of Abaddon
but even with this Victory the highest
levels of the SCP Foundation have an
ominous thought lurking in the back of
their minds where did o51 go and what is
he planning to do next
following the improper use of item 001
leading to the untimely death of a
high-ranking foundation staff member
the weapon was deemed too dangerous and
containment procedures were implemented
due to the high amount of radiation they
were found to admit the nine children
were placed into lead-lined bags and
buried under 50 meters of concrete
beneath the Church of San Marcos de la
Vida Eterna
though all of the children continued to
be functionally brain dead they still
displaced Signs of Life despite their
containment and by order of the overseer
Council have been classified as a
formula entity
the SCP Foundation deals with plenty of
different groups of Interest Colts rival
agencies criminal organizations all of
which have some connection to anomalous
artifacts and creatures but there are
some groups of interests who actually
are responsible for the creation of
anomalies and a few are as weird and
intriguing as the doctor wondertainment
toy company whether or not Dr
wondertainment is a real person or not
is the subject of much speculation but
whoever they are the company that bears
their name has produced a multitude of
dangerous anomalous items that are
currently in Foundation containment
usually these anomalies take the form of
Highly dangerous toys but the company
has also released a very peculiar set of
limited edition Creations a set of 21
living breathing more or less human
beings known collectively as the little
misters all of them are marked by
tattoos of their name and each comes
with a card reading wow you've just
found yourself your very own little
Mister a limited edition collection from
Dr wondertainment find them all and
become Mr collector let's take a look
and see what's out there before you try
and catch them all
scp-905 or Mr chameleon is a living
being made up entirely of photons his
form is described as fuzzy but definite
and he appears to be the rough shape of
a human male standing at approximately
175 centimeters in height he has no Mass
due to being made solely of light
particles at least not one we can
measure and while he can move and speak
he cannot manipulate objects in the
world around him Mr chameleon as his
name suggests can alter the wavelength
of the light coming from his body in
order to match the color of his
environment he also has the ability to
walk through any transparent material
scp-2287 or Mr headless is a human male
who is mostly normal aside from his lack
of a head Mr headless is blind but can
somehow still speak and hear and does
not need to eat spending time around Mr
headless can cause people to experience
dissociative episodes where they begin
to see themselves as headless as well in
an interview Mr headless claims to have
been created for use as a Halloween
decoration with his dissociative effect
on others being intended as a kind of
spooky prank even if it does sound more
like a form of torture Mr headless was
found by the foundation wandering the
streets of a Wisconsin town after he
left an attic where he had been kept
with other holiday decorations
scp-1799 or Mr laugh is a human male
standing 120 centimeters tall who has
the physical characteristics of a
classic circus clown complete with gray
and white skin a red nose and comically
long feet he is capable of communication
but everything he says will be
interpreted by those around him as a
joke no matter what he says people
around him will start to laugh and the
more he talks the more people laugh in
some cases they can even laugh
themselves to death for example one
d-class Personnel used to test the
effects of Mr laugh started laughing so
hard that he lost his balance and
suffered a fatal cranial injury
scp-909 or Mr forgetful is a man with
retrograde amnesia he appears aware of
his condition and cannot seem to recall
any of his own Memories the only way
that information appears able to enter
Mr forgetful's long-term memory is if he
writes it down however when he does so
something strange happens the memory
he's just written down is instantly
forgotten by anyone else who was
involved in the events
scp-3537 or Mr shapey is an amorphous
humanoid that changes shape though this
transformation happens involuntarily all
all of Mr shapey's Transformations are
into non-anomalous human beings and they
have been seen taking their own notes on
possible anomalous properties each new
persona could have they describe these
Transformations as painful with the
level of pain varying dependent on how
dramatic the change is despite the pain
Mr shapey says they're happy the way
they are in an interview they claim to
be the first of the little misters and
their random Transformations were used
as inspiration for the appearance of all
the subsequent little Mr designs
scp-1908 or Mr so is a man who
constantly produces soapy water which
will quickly fill up any area he's in
and cause all surrounding surfaces to
become slippery the soap can be easily
cleaned up with normal methods but the
levels of liquid being produced by Mr
soap's body have to be constantly
monitored when the foundation discovered
him he was in a factory in China where
he had been put to work clean the
Machinery
scp-913 or Mr Hungry is a middle-aged
African-American male wearing a dress
shirt and pants who is capable of eating
almost any material Mr Hungry has given
nutrients intravenously and must be
provided with a full day's worth of
calories every two hours or else he will
enter a hunger trance while in this
Trans State he is capable of biting with
a force of up to 5 000 Newtons and will
devour anything and everything around
him his metabolism is so fast that drugs
and toxins have no effect on him
including amnestics and anesthesia
scp-629 or Mr brass is a Massive Brass
automaton standing at 170 centimeters
and weighing 500 Kilograms all parts of
Mr brass's body are removable and can be
rearranged with only mild discomfort to
Mr brass himself projections show that
there are at least 73 billion possible
combinations of Mr brass's body Parts
when Mr brass was discovered by the
foundation he had been taken in by the
church of the broken God who believed
him to be a religious Idol and worshiped
him as a deity
scp-644 or Mr hot is a man who can both
accurately guess the number of children
that any person has biological or
otherwise and predict the material
wishes of any child he also claims to be
able to accurately predict the
popularity of any product aimed at
children when approached he will offer a
business card that identifies him as Dr
wondertainment's marketing consultant he
was found sleeping in the hallway of a
school in Racine Wisconsin a town that
was later found to contain many children
with anomalous wondertainment toys in
their possession in interviews Mr hot
describes his job as being able to
identify which children would get the
most use out of a wondertainment toy in
his own words you can't just give this
kind of craftsmanship to just anybody
you give the average kid a realistic
race car are he's just gonna go leave it
on a shelf and go stare at the Sun or
something
scp-2396 or Miss sweetie is a female
humanoid who stands at 250 centimeters
tall and weighs 101 kilograms she lives
entirely on sugar and foods containing
sugar and claims to be in pain when
denied her sweet fuel she has a
repellent effect on males a feature
which she says is meant to keep nasty
brothers and their friends out anomalous
hard candies will appear at random and
anywhere in a six kilometer radius of
Miss sweetie's location when adjusted by
females the candies are perfectly
harmless but any masculine presenting
humans who eat them start to undergo
transformation into a being made
entirely of living candy these candy
entities are resistant to blunt force
trauma but can be easily dispatched with
fire and will obey any command given to
them by any person who identifies as
female
scp-1007 or Mr life is a male humanoid
who goes through the entire human life
cycle every 75 minutes aging at a rate
of one year per minute Mr life has a key
hole in his back that when a key is
inserted into it can reverse the aging
process each turn of the key regresses
Mr life one year younger until he's
fully regressed to a newborn baby Mr
life was seized from a California
Mansion after he had been purchased at
an auction held by Marshall Carter and
dark limited another group of interests
that provides the wealthiest and most
powerful people in the world with
objects and experiences that would
otherwise be impossible without the help
of the anomalies they trade in other
little misters were also sold at the
auction though the buyer of Mr life
couldn't recall who they were or exactly
which little misters they had bought the
tattoo on Mr life's back reads Mr life
and Mr death which may imply that Mr
life has a counterpart that the
foundation has not yet been able to
identify as
scp-527 or Mr fish is a non-anomalous
man with no physical abnormalities of
any kind save for the fact that he has
the head of a fish he was discovered in
Boston in 2002 and moved to site 19 in
2004. in his initial interview with
Foundation researcher Dr Baker Mr Fish
was very Frank and upfront about his
lack of interesting qualities like I
told the other guy this is all it is
you're looking at it lies thrives hot
sweetie they got all the good stuff I'm
just the guy with the fish head
scp-917 or Mr moon is an elderly man
whose facial features Wax and Wane in
time with the lunar cycle on nights when
the moon is full his face is normal and
his face is completely blank on nights
with a new moon this is painless for Mr
moon but he does lose his sense of sight
hearing and smell when his face is in
its new moon State and he claims that
the experience leaves him very tired SCP
2855 or Mr money is a Latin American man
who is anomalously affected by any
business transactions regarding his
ownership as soon as any person
exchanges money for ownership of Mr
money and creates any kind of written
proof of that ownership Mr money will be
teleported to their location Mr money's
abilities are also subject to the
beliefs of whoever claims ownership of
him and will display any anomalous
properties that are written as part of
his contract Mr money was recovered in
2007 taken from the Holdings of Marshall
Carter and dark LLP a branch of the same
company that had previously sold Mr life
when Mr money was discovered mcnd had
been selling and buying him back
repeatedly in order to test his adaptive
capabilities
scp-920 or Mr lost is an Asian man in a
green hoodie who seems to do nothing but
wander aimlessly transportation and
containment of Mr lost are impossible as
any attempts to do so can result in a
variety of natural disasters and other
destructive phenomenon he has a kind of
psychic pull on those around him who
feel compelled to walk and talk with him
Mr loss doesn't seem to suffer from any
environmental effects as he has been
spotted wandering deserts and Tundra
with no apparent harm coming to him
whatsoever
scp-2284 or Mr Lai is a man of Indian
descent whose voice has a Cognito
hazardous effect on anyone who hears it
any statement that Mr Lai says will be
perceived as true despite the fact that
Mr Lai is physically incapable of
telling the truth because of this Mr Lai
communicates mainly via rhetorical
questions which is the only way he can
express what he means
scp-2428-1 or Mr mad is a man in a
multi-colored straitjacket who can only
be seen by those possessing the document
designated
scp-2428 a document which serves as
proof of perch
Mr mad is essentially an imaginary
friend who can only be seen by the lone
person in possession of the scp-2428
document in interviews Mr Matt expresses
a belief that he was a real person once
before being rendered imaginary by Dr
wondertainment in fact there is evidence
to suggest many of the little misters
were once Ordinary People
scp-2933 is a partially submerged steel
structure located in a saltwater
Reservoir a structure which contains
scp-2933-a or Mr scary the interior of
scp-2933 is constantly changing and
seems to move and shift in a way that
directs anyone who enters towards Mr
scary once inside the structure there is
no way back to the entrance despite his
name and despite the sense of dreads
surrounding the steel structure Mr scary
doesn't seem interested in scaring
people he self-identifies as Mr miles
and seems to have the personality of a
young child his body is like his
containment covered in Rust a condition
which he claims was transferred to him
by his father and which he says is very
painful while he does have a tattoo
naming him Mr Smiles a rusted patch of
his skin appears to have been marked
with Mr scary property of the factory
suggesting that they may have had
something to do with his rusted
condition
scp-2148 or Mr Stripes is a man wearing
a white blindfold if the blindfold is
removed anything that Mr Stripes tries
to commit to memory whether that's a
passage of text a scene from a movie or
a person's face becomes censored by
large black bars in all existing records
Mr Stripes refers to Mr Lai as his
brother and believes himself to be the
first little Mister although he was told
that by Mr lies so take it with a grain
of salt based on Mr Stripes testimony Mr
lies spent a lot of time with him
traveling around and making use of their
combined abilities to break into secure
government buildings even though they
were close Mr Stripes has never directly
looked at Mr Lai as he tells it Dr
wondertainment told him they weren't
supposed to look at Mr lion and then
last but not least is Mr red who has not
been given a designation and is listed
as a discontinued little Mister his
story is a topic that would take an
entire video to explain altogether but
he may just be the most violent powerful
and dangerous of all the little misters
as interesting as the little misters are
they're not the only anomalous creatures
of the mysterious doctor wondertainment
so let us know in the comments if you'd
like to hear more about this Twisted toy
maker after all nothing makes you feel
more like a child at heart than running
in Terror from a doctor wondertainment
original you're driving down a long
Highway lost in an area you don't know
too well trying to find the right turn
that'll have you heading back towards
your home you keep driving the nighttime
quiet all around you deciding to try and
break that silence you reach for the
radio turning the dial to filter through
all the garbled distorted voices and
songs from nearby local radio stations
that are too far out of range to come
through clearly you try your best to
listen to the music from One radio
station but eventually the sound of the
static only makes you wish for the
silence you were trying to break your
fingers nudge the tuning dial on your
car radio once again and finally
something comes through it isn't loud or
clear but under the Distortion you can
make out the sound and it isn't a song
or even a late news broadcast the first
thing you hear sounds like a short
musical tone only for about 10 seconds
next a young girl's voice speaking in a
language you don't understand
even through the distorted audio from
her accent you assume it's Russian but
you still have no idea what the word
she's saying mean with nothing else to
listen to you let the broadcast play
still driving alone in the dark with
nothing but the strange adolescent voice
to accompany you your mind begins to
wander she sounds like she's speaking
something but the rhythm of the words is
somehow familiar to you even though you
don't speak Russian then it hits you
she's counting but you don't feel smart
for having worked that out instead
something about knowing that makes your
blood run cold you carry on driving
through the night after a few short
minutes the Russian girl stops counting
and the musical tone plays again under
the Distortion leaving you alone in the
car once again with nothing but your
thoughts and questions of what exactly
you just heard thankfully we have the
answer what you heard was
scp-3034 since 1964 this same broadcast
has been made a vast number of times
627 times in fact you'd have to be
within two kilometers of the broadcast's
point of origin to hear it where
Foundation Personnel have tried and
failed numerous times to triangulate its
source the numbers heard recited in the
scp-3034 broadcast are actually a
countdown from 200 read aloud in Russian
all Foundation staff are able to Zoo
while stationed at the nearby
provisional site 3034 is scour radio
frequencies for occurrences of
scp-3034 checking their equipment is
properly maintained and calibrated
before they are eventually rotated
off-site and replaced with a new group
of staff there is only one rule that any
foundation members working at
provisional site 3034 must follow they
are only permitted to send one radio
transmission with their equipment a
single phrase in reply to the scp-3034
broadcast
receiving this the countdown stops and
the broadcast ends but never permanently
scp-3034 has been known to repeatedly
occur seemingly at random the shortest
recorded gap between broadcasts was two
weeks while the longest so far lasted
six whole months you may have heard the
term Numbers Station mentioned before
but these are far from just random
numerical sequences sent out over the
airwaves without purpose General
speculation surrounding number stations
points to them being the tools of
Espionage agents a way of sending coded
highly sensitive messages or information
without the risk of compromising their
cover the use of number station
Transmissions is often attributed to
spies working on foreign soil who
utilize shortwave radio frequencies
speech synthesis Morse code and either
regular or sporadic timing schedules
while it's true that times have changed
and technology has progressed
considerably there appears to be
evidence that number stations are still
used among various intelligence and
Espionage agencies today despite being
considered an old-fashioned method of
communication these low-tech shortwave
stations remain a viable reliable option
for the transmission and reception of
intelligence to field agents the konet
project is a comprehensive Archive of
this phenomenon and its founder Aiken
Fernandez has long been fascinated by
number stations according to him them
this system is completely secure because
the messages can't be tracked the
recipient could be anywhere you just
send spies to the country and get them
to buy a radio they know where to tune
and when so what does the distorted
broadcast of numbers from scp-3034 mean
is it the work of covert agents and if
so whose side are they on most
importantly why does the SCP Foundation
make certain there are always three of
its Personnel on site ready to send the
all is well message whenever scp-3034
begins broadcasting
scp-3034 was first discovered by the
foundation in 1964 after a Defector from
the Soviet grup a division tasked with
acquiring and studying anomalies on
behalf of the USSR gave them a temp
Commander Robert malphus along with a
team of six including a man named agent
Browning selected for his knowledge of
Russian dialects were sent to
investigate at provisional site 3034
here the team uncovered partially burned
records and log books all kept in
Russian along with evidence that the
site had been evacuated shortly before
their arrival carved into a desk also in
Russian were two phrases don't let her
finish and tell her all is well on the
team's second day at the site an
automated alarm sounded at 7 30 am
alerting them to the incoming scp-3034
broadcast following the instructions on
the desk agent Browning was able to stop
the broadcast telling the young Russian
girl that all was well a tape was
partially recovered by the team from the
site and translated from Russian the
grup members that had previously
inhabited the station had interrogated
one of their own a man named Sergey whom
they accused of stealing State Property
she's not State Property he replied she
has a name while his grup Superior
accused Sergey of planning to defect to
the United States allegedly in exchange
for money and Asylum Sergey denied any
collusion with America he claimed that
the grup at provisional site-3034 were
meddling with powers they could not
possibly hope to understand his Superior
a man named vaslov dismissed this
claiming their work to be no different
to the United States experimentation
with atomic weapons at the time one does
not make deals with atom bombs Sergey
argued one certainly does not sacrifice
little girls to them shortly after this
a struggle broke out with Sergey having
to be restrained while urging vaslov to
cease any and all interference with it
the man spoke of terrible nightmares
that he'd had voices screaming in the
darkness that's what they once was
that's what it is you cannot make a deal
with this thing we have finally
contained it and now you want to offer
it the tapes audio ends shortly after
this point with no clear answer as to
what Sergey was referring to or what
offered these Russian operatives had
made to it ever since the discovery of
scp-3034 members of the SCP Foundation
have worked tirelessly to understand the
purpose of these countdowns as well as
determine their origin by September 2012
Dr shokil was reaching the end of his
tether with the investigation into the
scp-3034 broadcast over almost half a
century the foundation had made well
over 600 recordings of the Russian girls
countdowns but still hadn't determined
any noteworthy information they were
prohibited from contacting the girl via
the same radio frequency only permitted
to use the phrase that stopped her
countdowns running out of options she'll
kill contacted his colleague Dr Emerson
asking for an in-depth vocal analysis of
the various recordings of
scp-3034 even if they could narrow down
where the broadcast was coming from
Maybe by determining the girl's
geographical location from her dialect
then that would be at least some slight
progress into understanding
scp-3034 while unable to discover the
girl's location doc Dr Emerson's
analysis did yield some interesting
findings Emerson learned that these
countdowns were not pre-recorded the
variations in the Russian girl's voice
her tone her pitch all seemed to
indicate that every instance of the
broadcast was unique rather than use the
same recording this girl had been
counting down over and over hundreds of
times for almost 50 years but there was
more shulkill and Emerson then examined
the Distortion The Sounds interfering
with the audio of the Russian girls
countdowns what had initially seemed
like garbled static seemed to actually
be additional voices and much like the
girl's voice these distorted voices were
unique different in every broadcast
however show kill and Emerson were
unable to accurately determine what
these voices were saying given that the
girls countdowns were always cut short
by the use of the phrase all is well the
doctors did not have long enough samples
of the audio to analyze the other
distorted voices with permission from
the foundation the next five occurrences
of the scp-3034 broadcast were allowed
to carry on for longer giving the two
doctors enough audio to determine
exactly what the distorted voices were
and the results were extremely troubling
they were screams thousands upon
thousands of children's voices endlessly
screaming both Dr Emerson and Dr
shulkill agreed that it would be best to
continue responding to scp-3034 with the
correct phrase and refused to analyze
the distorted screaming audio any
further three years later while
stationed at provisional site-3034 a
foundation researcher named Dr Uriel
Willis decided to take matters into her
own hands she conducted an experiment
that had not been sanctioned by the
foundation and attempted to make contact
with the Russian girl giving the
countdowns hearing Dr Willis's voice the
girl stopped her countdown after five
long painfully silent seconds a new
broadcast was heard a piercing
high-pitched Screech that caused extreme
pain and dizziness to all the staff
working on site unable to Bear the
disorienting sound Dr Willis told the
girl all is well and caused the noise to
stop the following day SCP researchers
noted that there had been a significant
increase in cases of missing children
all around the world a majority of these
disappearances happened at the same time
the Screech had been broadcast and
remain unsolved to this day Dr Willis
faced disciplinary action from the SCP
Foundation and any further testing of
scp-3034 and attempts to communicate
with the Russian girl were prohibited
only one distinct change has been noted
in the scp-3034 broadcast since this
incident almost a month later the
countdown was detected in the correct
phrase given but researchers noted that
instead of starting her countdown from
200 this time the Russian girl began and
counting down from 199 nobody knows what
will happen if the Russian girls
countdown is allowed to reach zero
Personnel working at provisional site
3034 are told to always offer her the
necessary phrase before this point in
the countdown attempting to interfere
with the broadcast by contacting this
girl directly not only resulted in
intense pain for SCP staff but also
seems to have caused an unconfirmed
number of child disappearances around
the globe as well as reducing the
countdown starting number from 200 to
199. after a long night on the road you
finally find the right turn sending you
in the right direction as you drive
through the night you keep telling
yourself one thing one small phrase over
and over again you hope the words will
eventually give you comfort but deep
down you start to realize just how
hollow they are that it's just a lie we
tell ourselves so we don't have to face
the inevitable but
what choice do you have but to keep
telling yourself that all is well as we
all know the SCP Foundation secures
contains and protects the various
anomalies under its custody but their
mission isn't limited to just grabbing
the object and chucking it into a
containment Locker at the bottom of a
classified site deep below the surface
of the Earth the foundation wants to get
a comprehensive full understanding of
all the strange items creatures and
humanoids in its custody because that's
the only way to understand what they're
capable of what danger they pose and how
to effectively contain them that much is
logical but the problem is that there's
no Global scientific Community
surrounding anomalies at least not ones
willing to cooperate with the foundation
perhaps the chaos Insurgency or Global
occult Coalition have some scientists
who have studied anomalies or the
various government agencies that know
about the anomalous world like the
unusual incidence unit or Soviet grup
but for the most part the foundation is
utterly alone when it comes to figuring
out how these anomalies work what they
are and how to combat them so the
foundation does what any institution
would do experiments many of the
foundation's most important and iconic
anomalies are defined by the experiments
the white-coated scientists have
performed on them sometimes even using
human subjects through the notorious and
Infamous d-class program everyone knows
about how scp-682 the hard to destroy
lizard has been subjected to practically
every known weapon and attack Under the
Sun in an attempt to kill the highly
dangerous hateful predator and who can
forget scp-914 the Clockworks and the
countless objects the foundation has put
through it on its five settings to see
what it spits out needless to say the
foundation's experiments are incredibly
important to how the organization
functions so those scps that can offer
lots of testing options are very
treasured and prized along with being
iconic and legendary throughout the
foundation today we're going to be
looking at one such anomaly but not a
dangerous hostile man-eating Predator
like scp-682 or a mysterious Eldritch
machine like scp-914 now today we're
going to be looking at something much
more simpler than that a coffee machine
yes today we're going to be inspecting
scp-294 affectionately referred to by
guards and personnel as the coffee
machine though you probably don't want
to order a hot cup of joe in this coffee
machine lest you well let's not get
ahead of ourselves the first thing you
see when you open the scp-294 file is
its number of course item 294 object
class Euclid the next thing you see is
the image if you were imagining a tiny
little coffee maker before this should
get rid of that
scp-294 is big the kind of coffee
machine you'd see in a factory break
room it's almost the size of a vending
machine and has a big colored window
showing a few cups of coffee along with
the slots for cash and coins so drinkers
can pay for their espressos but the most
notable feature on scp-294 is the full
keyboard on the front panel it's a
typical qwerty keyboard just like yours
with a space bar and everything why on
Earth would a coffee machine need a
keyboard the special containment
procedures paint an interesting picture
by which we mean there aren't any
scp-294 doesn't need any special
procedures secret rituals or complex
machines to keep it contained but it's
still Euclid so only Personnel who have
security clearance of level 2 or higher
are allowed to interact with it at the
moment this is surprising when you
realize that scp-294 is currently being
held not an anomalous item Locker or
containment cell but exactly where you'd
expect to find a big coffee machine a
break room specifically the site 19
second floor Personnel break room but
it's not alone it's monitored by two
guards with level 3 clearance around the
clock for them sitting in the break room
all day guarding a coffee machine that
can't move and is too heavy to lift has
to be a pretty sweet gig considering
what other kinds of jobs are available
at the foundation but all that raises
even more Mysteries what the heck is up
with this coffee machine the description
starts off obvious enough affirm that
yes scp-294 is indeed a standard coffee
vending machine but with the difference
we all noticed earlier instead of a
simple button list of options it has a
full keyboard on it each button aligning
with the letter on a real keyboard and
when someone slips 50 cents into the
coin slot quite a bargain for coffee if
you ask me the user gets a message on
screen prompting them to enter the name
of what liquid they'd like you type it
in on the keyboard and that's that the
machine drops a little paper cup and a
nozzle shoots out 12 fluid ounces of
whatever you requested pretty nifty
isn't it but it gets niftier most people
would only think to ask a coffee machine
for well coffee but scp-294 accepts any
liquid and some things that aren't
liquids when the foundation initially
got their hands on it they ran no less
than 97 tests on it after they realized
they weren't just limited to espressos
and cappuccinos at first any kind of
liquid you could drink was requested the
researchers popped in requests for water
coffee Beer soda milkshakes and out they
came then they decided to get a little
more creative they started to request
things you couldn't possibly drink not
if you wanted to stay alive sulfuric and
hydrochloric acid like the kind scp-682
is suspended in wiper fluid motor oil
but scp-294 stubbornly provided even if
the liquids would melt through the
researchers throats like a knife through
butter then the research researchers
decided to apply some of their
scientific knowledge there are a lot of
chemical compounds that don't usually
exist in a liquid state on planet
Earth's surface they typed in nitrogen
iron and glass among others and received
shimmering liquids and paper cups they
sent them off to a lab for analysis and
wouldn't you know it chemically
identical to nitrogen iron and glass but
when they typed in Diamond no doubt
wondering whether they'd found an
infinite Cash Cow they received an error
message on the screen it seemed that
while scp-294 could deliver substances
that aren't usually in a liquid state on
Earth's surface it needed to be at least
possible for the substance to be in a
pure liquid form for scp-294 to dispense
it since diamond is only a mineral it
couldn't be dispensed then they tried to
test something else and got a slightly
disturbing response on the small LCD
display out of stock it stopped
responding to requests for over an hour
then made a small noise and began to
accept requests again it appears that
the machine can take about 50 requests
before needing to take an hour and a
half to restock itself and while only
the machine is anomalous the small 12
ounce paper cups it dispenses its
liquids in seems remarkably Hardy
substances that would have eaten through
paper instantly like the sulfuric acid
and hydrochloric acid had no effect on
these little cups though the same can be
said for those that drank from them one
of the researchers had a great idea here
was an anomaly that was practically
harmless and could be a great little way
for the foundation to scale back its
budget a little bit they propose putting
scp-294 into the break room it currently
resides in both to more easily conduct
experiments and to save money when
agents and doctors came in for lunch and
needed a quick drink or in the mornings
where everyone was looking for coffee to
wake them up with no good reason not to
the machine was put in the break room
but no not long after an unfortunate
incident occurred one with enough harm
that it was deemed necessary that only
personnel with security clearance
interact with scp-294 what could have
happened to cause this did someone burn
themselves on hot coffee did the vending
machine accidentally Crush someone no
the reality is much darker one morning
in August of 2005 agent Joseph whose
full name has been redacted to preserve
their identity went up to the vending
machine in the break room looking to get
a hot cup of coffee to wake himself up
between shifts another agent in the room
who was on break at the time saw him and
made a suggestion to find out what
scp-294 would do when given the
colloquial name rather than the exact
real name of a drink they just wanted to
see what would happen so agent Joseph
slipped in two quarters and typed in a
hot cup of joe seconds after he began
sweating like a pig it was feeling very
hot even though the break room was fully
air conditioned and his skin began to
flush he then clutched his head
complaining that he was dizzy and the
whole room was spinning around before
collapsing to the floor the other agent
immediately called the medical staff who
Moved agent Joseph to the infirmary and
stabilized him once they made sure he
wasn't in any real trouble they also
grabbed whatever scp-294 had spit out it
was a disgusting thick reddish brown
liquid with a strong stench and when
they ran the labs on it they confirmed
it was exactly what they thought it was
a mixture of blood tissue bone marrow
cerebrospinal fluid and other bodily
fluids that was an exact DNA match for
agent Joseph
scp-294 somehow managed to literally
liquefy 12 ounces from the agent's body
before producing them into a cup this
offered a clue maybe it stole the
liquids it was asked for or from the
nearest source in any case the agent was
released after a few weeks of bed rest
and care to make sure he wasn't further
injured and both involved agents were
reprimanded with the knowledge of how
accidentally dangerous scp-294 can be
who can blame the foundation for wanting
to keep a careful lid on it researchers
were curious though and received
clearance to test the scp's abilities to
retrieve specific liquids from long
distances with an o5's approval and
oversight they input a cup of
scp-075's secretion
scp-075 the corrosive snail is exactly
what it sounds like a gross little
creature that secretes a highly Caustic
Acid capable of melting almost anything
without fail the coffee machine
dispensed the secretion into the cup and
the cup stayed perfectly intact but at
the very same time in scp-075 cell the
creature woke up and began secreting
acid that immediately appeared all in
all about 12 ounces the same amount in
the cup based off these results further
testing with scp-294 was approved one
researcher tried punching in a request
for a cup of gold what came out was a
small paper cup of molten gold that
quickly cooled to room temperature
asking for cups of silver and platinum
produce similar results but based off of
previous tests it seemed clear that the
machine wasn't creating precious metals
so much as siphoning them off from
somewhere else the next request was a
strange one a cup of anti-water the
machine took a moment then printed a
small message on its LCD display out of
range this confirmed that the machine
couldn't produce substances that didn't
actually exist and couldn't break
physics to get its materials by peering
into alternate universes Dimensions or
realities after that the researchers
tested for diamond and got the result
that you already know of and out of
range error some more investigations
show that all solid substances that
don't have a liquid form get this error
but asking for a cup of liquid carbon
produced exactly that because liquid
carbon isn't the same thing as a diamond
though both are made of carbon
scp-294 clearly has more knowledge of
chemistry than some of us then the
researchers created an entirely new
drink made of bleach various sodas
protein powders and spices they blended
it together and put it in a jar across
the room from scp-294 when requested the
amount of the liquid in the cup was
missing from the jar proving that
scp-294 doesn't actually create its own
liquids but how does scp-294 react when
presented with a more subjective request
one researcher asked for the best drink
I've ever had after a moment the paper
cup filled with something that looked
like Cola but the researcher said it
tasted like a drink he had years ago at
a party and that he'd always is
remembered as his favorite drink though
he couldn't say what was in it but that
was a subjective test and the
researchers repeated it with a different
subject when an agent also requested the
best drink I've ever had the machine
produced a simple Vienna lager with a
label showing a group of people drinking
it at the beach and no brand name the
agent confirmed that the best drink he
ever had was a Vienna lager at the beach
with his friends so scp-294 could not
only read people's minds it can read
memories they don't even know they still
have another one they tried was
something Cassie will like referencing
scp-085 the young girl who lived in a
drawn on world the cup dispensed was
completely empty but it had a small
drawing printed on the side of a soda
glass with brown and white things
floating on top of each other the
researchers presented the cup to Cassie
and were told by her it was a chocolate
banana milkshake and a delicious one at
that a cup of music was a strange
request and produced an even stranger
result a clear odorless carbonated drink
that tasted vaguely alcoholic when drunk
subjects said they could feel it and
started showing an affinity to music
being able to sing and dance to a rhythm
when they had no sense of Rhythm or were
tone deaf before whether scp-294 can
produce even more abstract Concepts is
still under study but was interrupted by
the next test an unfortunate Containment
Breach incident at site 19 left several
Personnel trapped in the break room
heavily injured while mtfs fought to
re-establish control over the site an
agent typed in a cup of medical
knowledge and the Machine quickly
produced a green liquid after drinking
it the agent was able to treat the
injuries of their fellow Personnel
consistent with standard first responder
practices and was commended for The
Bravery but their knowledge didn't stick
around after the breach and attempts to
recreate the liquid failed they decided
that scp-294 broke its own rules for
self-preservation in the emergency
implying that it's not only sentient it
is intelligent a doctor using scp-294
made a request close to him my life's
story while nowhere close to a drink
scp-294 seemed to accept the input until
it started shaking violently and making
odd noises it remained in this new state
for about three minutes then returned to
normal spitting out a completely opaque
black fluid like tar in a cup despite
the strange reaction the doctor drank
the fluid and immediately informed the
others he was now able to remember
everything that had ever happened to him
from the smallest childhood event to the
most important events in his adult life
he excused himself and disappeared into
his office the next time the staff saw
him two days later he was carrying an
autobiography 600 pages long then the
researchers decided to try their luck
and input surprise me the resulting
solution was a cup containing What
seemed to be regular water right until a
researcher touched it it was just water
all right but it had been superheated to
200 degrees Celsius while remaining in
liquid form the moment someone touched
it bang it violently evaporated into
steam spraying boiling water everywhere
not only does scp-294 have intelligence
it has a sense of humor albeit a quite
rude one the next three requests were
for blood namely blood of the Smilodon
or saber-toothed tiger of the passenger
pigeon and a Founding Father Thomas
Jefferson but the only thing scp-294
produced were out of range errors
confirming it can't take liquids that
don't exist anymore but in the next test
blood was received from wolves saliva
was received from horses urine was
received from koalas and cerebral spinal
fluid was received from foibromus
pattersoni a rodent that went extinct
distinct some 8 million years ago though
if scp-294 is working according to its
own rules it means that there may be
still one in the wild somehow for the
next test the researchers decided to get
back to the scientific roots of it all
they made a request for a cup of
d-151839s leukemia knowing that the
d-class in question had a very Advanced
case of cancer the machine outputted it
without any trouble and Analysis of the
liquid showed it contained cancer cells
that match the d-class's DNA but another
request for the same spat out and out of
range error what's more a medical
checkup on the d-class revealed that
their tumor was completely gone but
unfortunately it was only a short-term
fix the cancer cells recurred within two
weeks of the test
scp-294 initially just seemed like a
boring magic vending machine but it was
only after the extensive experimentation
that you just saw a shortened log of
that the SCP Foundation was able to
discern its true nature it was wasn't an
unthinking object it was sentient
intelligent and even a little sarcastic
though none of that stopped it from
doing its job providing people with a
hot cup of whatever they needed to drink
just make sure you type in your request
very carefully what's the largest animal
you can think of okay that's probably
too vague of a question your mind
probably went straight to the oceans
picturing deep sea leviathans like the
mighty blue whale let's go a little bit
closer shall we what about on land what
are the biggest animals that live up
here with us above the water elephants
maybe what about rhinos then again
hippos are up there too in the same kind
of ballpark all pretty huge what about
cows they can grow pretty big right
especially with all the crazy growth
hormones that meat manufacturers pump
into them these days well what if there
was something out there bigger than all
of those imagine it some huge Beast
roaming the Wilderness that easily
towered above any creature you've ever
seen in your life this thing would be
massive striding across the world
towering above the meager height of a
human being now imagine that this thing
whatever it was wasn't just big but kept
getting bigger sure all of this might
sound like the premise for the next
Godzilla or Cloverfield movie but while
big Charlie might not be the king of the
monsters it certainly lives up to that
first part of its nickname of course the
SCP Foundation calls it
scp-4158 big Charlie is just the playful
nickname that the owners gave it
although none of them are sure who was
the first to call the creature by that
name standing on four long legs at 3.4
meters tall when the foundation first
discovered it
scp-4158 was about one and three-fifths
times as tall as famous professional
basketball player Shaquille O'Neal but
since then well like we said big Charlie
is getting bigger day by day the
creature appears to be tangentally
related to the bovine family of mammals
essentially making it a ginormous cow
however
scp-4158 lacks the facial structure and
features that you might expect to see on
the faces at your local Farm the
creature has thin translucent skin which
is so fragile that it often tears easily
and anyone observing scp-4158 can often
see the bones and internal organs within
gross it possesses a large bulbous head
with a protrusion at the front almost
like a beak as well as that its huge
eyes are foggy a milky white color which
seems to suggest that scp-4158 is at
least partially blind the large Cadillac
mammal is incredibly skinny almost to
the point where its bones stick out from
underneath its skin its legs are longer
than the rest of its colossal body and
seen barely able to support the animal's
weight on description alone you can't
help but feel sorry for the poor
creature and its sorry state of living
normally big Charlie is mostly common
docile barely acknowledging the
foundation Personnel that come to
examine it feed it or clean its
containment cell held in a heavy
containment zone
scp-4158 is fed through a five meter
trough on the far East wall of its cell
surviving on a diet of raw beef hay wood
and Bricks not the typical grass-only
eating habits you'd expect from normal
cows but according to the foundation's
extensive testing on the creature its
diet doesn't seem to be what is causing
scp-4158 to keep growing at the rate it
has been the mass of big Charlie is in
some sort of state of Perpetual increase
meaning its size and weight are always
growing and it is because of this
continuous growth that every week the
foundation is forced to Shear off great
swaths of excess meat from the creature
cleaving off its flesh and incinerating
the mass all while big Charlie is still
alive now before you start dialing
peta's hotline it's also worth
mentioning big Charlie can't feel pain
what's more testing has revealed that
the meat taken from scp-4158 is USDA
utility grade beef the kind that would
normally come from older cattle utility
grade meat has no fat marbling so it
isn't as tender or as flavoursome as
other more premium grades but would
normally be used in canned and processed
food products and despite the foundation
destroying the excess that they cut off
of big Charlie as a precaution in theory
the meat is still good to eat and
possesses no anomalous properties then
again would you really want to eat a
burger made from
scp-4158 I didn't think so if left
unchecked and allowed to grow for longer
than a week
scp-4158 will begin to form new features
limbs organs and sometimes even genitals
will Sprout from random places all over
its body the previous record for Big
Charlie's most substantial growth was
when he increased to eight and a half
meters tall that's over three fifths the
height of the Hollywood sign and over
one and a half times the average height
of a giraffe at this immense size
Charlie has developed seven legs four
stomachs three tongues and numerous
other extremities before the SCP
Foundation cut him back down to size and
we mean they literally cut him back down
so what exactly is this thing it's like
a giant cow but not actually a cow even
though its flesh is identical to beef
and it's not a destructive rampaging
monster either showing no hostility
towards humans even when they are
shearing its excessive body mass away
could it be some kind of failed genetic
experiment an attempt to solve hunger by
engineering a creature that could not
only stay alive but keep growing after
having its meat cut away if that were
true it would make scp-4158 a literal
Cash Cow for the meat industry well
we've got kind of a funny story about
that actually big Charlie was first
encountered by the foundation back in
December 2004 in crudson Indiana a
number of calls have been made to the
area's local animal control services
with reports of a large cow with mange
roaming the nearby Highway 17. two
officers belonging to the animal Control
Department were sent out to investigate
these reports and what they found was
scp-4158 wandering aimlessly but unlike
any cow they had ever seen the officers
called local police where a foundation
plant caught wind of what they had found
and called in containment Specialists
the case was closed after the Animal
Control Officers were given amnestics
and a cover story was put in place about
a cow with mange that was put down where
it had been found in reality the SCP
Foundation rounded up old big Charlie
and transported it to safety with Little
Resistance from the animal they were
able to trace the creature's origin back
to somewhere called Butcher's Block a
nearby slaughterhouse the manager of the
establishment one Jeff fine and a single
employee named Barney Mossman were
brought in by the foundation for
questioning another employee Rory Gilson
was also retrieved from his home after
having called in sick to work that day
Barney Mossman the first of the
Butcher's Block employees to be
interviewed stated that scp-4158 had
been called Big Charlie since long
before he had started his job at the
slaughterhouse according to his
testimony he knew nothing about where
the creature had actually come from only
that it was fed hay but would also
occasionally eat anything else it could
including other cows since joining
Butcher's Block four years earlier
Mossman had been told not to ask
questions or to tell anyone else about
scp-4158 the morning after the huge
creature had seemingly escaped Mr fine
had apparently angrily accused both
Barney and Rory of selling him out and
giving big Charlie away to the
competitors of Butcher's Block even
though they were the only slaughterhouse
in the area but Mossman was convinced
that neither of them were capable of
doing something like that Roy apparently
treated big Charlie like his own child
and fine had an even stranger
relationship with the creature Rory
Gilson the other of Fine's employees was
more helpful in shedding light on
scp-4158's Origin than Barney had been
Rory explained that he and Jeff fine had
bought a pregnant cow from an unknown
person nine years earlier considering it
to be a steal a two for the price of one
bargain however one day without warning
the calf fell out of its mother it
wasn't born like any ordinary cow
however according to guildsen it had
ripped through the mother cow's chest
and looked disgusting while Rory and
Jeff had initially thought the calf to
be dead they discovered it had tried to
get back into the barn after they hauled
it outside their original intention had
been to sell the creature off for
scientific study or failing that to a
freak Show however after their attempts
to sell the calf failed Jeff and Rory
had decided the best course of action
would be to put the animal down they had
reason that releasing it into the wild
could have negatively affected the
ecosystem so instead they took a bolt
pistol and pushed it between the
creature's eyes then fired but nothing
happened Roy tried again but ended up
breaking the gun instead they slit the
animal's throat but it barely bled even
butchering it on the Spot while it was
still alive did nothing finding Guild
sin reduced the calf to little more than
a skeleton but it simply refused to Die
the pair of them packaged the meat they
had removed with the rest hoping no one
would notice or ask where it had come
from it was a few days later that Roy
realized scp-4158 was capable of
regrowing whatever was cut off of it he
and his boss even tried some and
couldn't tell the difference they had
their hands on a cow that would eat
anything put in front of it and that
could produce infinite meat the
foundation probed Rory Gilson further
for more information on the creature
learning that scp-4158 was sterile and
incapable of reproducing the only one of
its kind Rory argued that the foundation
legally couldn't take big Charlie away
that the creature was still private
property little did he realize he was
wrong but he just like Barney Mossman
also knew nothing about how the animal
had escaped in the first place finally
Jeff fine the owner of the Butcher's
Block slaughterhouse was questioned by
the foundation he repeated Rory's
earlier story about the strange calf
that had been born and how it could
regenerate the flesh that was sheared
off of it fine remarks that he
considered it to be a blessing when
asked about his whereabouts on the night
scp-4158 had escaped from Butcher's
Block Jeff admitted that he had been
praying but not to God to Big Charlie he
had apparently been doing this every
night since realizing what the creature
could do viewing the animal as a
provider and a savior I just felt
something when I was around him I could
tell that he wanted to make this
sacrifice for us ever since he tried to
get into the barn after we threw him out
I knew he cared for us fine told the
foundation I would open his pen take off
my clothes so that I was pure before him
laid down and receive His blessings and
how would he receive those Blessings by
drinking the animal's blood yeah Jeff
fine was a real eccentric like that one
night when fine had entered the pen to
perform this weird ritual big Charlie
had escaped but his owner was convinced
that there must have been a reason for
this that the animal had some sort of
goal when the foundation staff
conducting Fine's interview dismissed
this idea The Slaughterhouse owner
became enraged how dare you question big
Charlie he knows what's best for all of
us I'm done here I don't need to keep
answering questions like this let me out
I need to see big Charlie I need to see
if he's safe the foundation believes
that Jeff finds practice of worshiping
scp-4158 was not due to any anomalous
effect caused by the creature itself
none of the foundation Personnel tasked
with feeding studying and shearing meat
off of big Charlie have displayed any
similar behavior of Performing abnormal
religious rituals he really was just
just a huge weirdo as for the Butcher's
Block slaughterhouse fine and the rest
of his employees were giving him knee
sticks to forget big Charlie had ever
even existed and the slaughterhouse was
closed under the false pretense of a
health code violation and its staff
being arrested for malpractice the one
question that remains unanswered however
is the identity of the individual that
first sold Jeff fine the cow that gave
birth to
scp-4158 it just goes to show you though
sometimes you don't know where your food
is coming from if you lived in Indiana
in late 2004 who knows you might have
eaten some of big Charlie and not even
realized it did you ever have to perform
a dissection in school maybe you had to
carve up a fetal pig or slice into a
frog while nightmarish visions of Kermit
and a widowed Miss Piggy danced in your
head though it's rarely a pleasant
experience unless your tastes are on The
Morbid side most biology teachers would
agree that the best way to learn how
something works is to take it apart as
distasteful as it can be to hold a
frog's tiny liver in your hands it
definitely does give you a better sense
of the pieces that make up the complete
creature but what if there was an easier
way to look at the individual parts of a
living being what if you could take it
apart without ever having to prep a
scalpel or stain your hands with the
blood of innocent frogs like most of the
seemingly impossible things in our world
the SCP Foundation discovered something
that allows its users to do just that in
fact it can handle a lot more than just
a frog and its applications go far
beyond the confines of a high school
science lab
scp-291 is a small plain steel building
with a large door on one side the door
has no handle or knob and functions
similarly to a garage door the door
cannot be pried open by any ordinary
means and the inside of scp-291 can only
be accessed if the structure is
connected to a suitable power source
once a power source has been connected
the door races and exposes a room inside
it is small about four by two meters it
contains a console board a large screen
and a Plexiglas container resembling a
coffin how very Sinister the coffin is
large enough to contain a human under
seven feet tall so sorry Ferdinand the
cannibal you're going to need to sit
this one out the coffin sits on a
conveyor belt with several tubes
connected to the wall above it on the
opposite side of the room there are
holes of varying sizes each containing a
small door that can be opened or closed
because initial observation indicated
that scp-291 was intended for some kind
of human testing a d-class test subject
was selected for experimentation the
subject was instructed to lie down in
the coffin and wait to see what would
happen next the display screen lit up
depicting a grid lined image of the test
subject buttons along the console board
adjusted the image showing the skin
muscles and organ systems of the person
in the coffin there were no words or
numbers on the screen and all of the
buttons appeared to have only two
settings on and off when one of the
researchers pressed the first button on
the console the tubes above the coffin
began pouring a blue liquid into it the
test subject reacted with confusion but
did not experience any adverse effects
they quickly lost Consciousness
indicating that the liquid was some sort
of sedative the liquid continued to pour
into the coffin until the vessel was
completely filled at which point it
congealed into a thick gel the test
subject's breathing and heartbeat slowed
to a stop and the conveyor belt suddenly
creaked to life the coffin was carried
test subject inside through a small door
that immediately locked behind it the
small room was filled with the sounds of
Gears turning Machinery clinking and
Motors whirring the display screen was
taken over by a large rectangle
resembling a traditional loading screen
after 30 minutes the process was
complete and the back door of the room
unlocked itself when the researcher
walked through the back door they found
another room with a conveyor belt and a
row of two dozen lockers each Locker was
opened one at a time and its contents
removed for examination inside each the
research team found a different portion
of the test subject's body in a block of
some unidentified clear substance the
body was divided in the lockers into
these separate parts brain lungs and
diaphragm heart digestive system
reproductive organs left eye right eye
upper left torso and arm upper right
torso and arm lower left torso and upper
leg lower right torso and upper leg
lower left leg and foot lower right leg
and foot lower left arm and hand lower
right arm and hand neck and head upper
skeletal system lower skeletal system
lymphatic and circulatory system and
skin
the miracle of the human body right
boundless in its fascinating
complexities each block of body parts
was placed back in its designated locker
and the second button on the console was
pressed at this point the doors to the
organ lockers sealed themselves shut and
the sound of the Machinery working
filled the small space once again this
continued for a duration of
approximately 45 minutes when the
Machinery went silent a new Plexiglas
coffin emerged into the main room with
the test subject inside he looked
identical to how he had looked at the
start of the experiment with no evidence
that he had previously been disassembled
the blue liquid slowly evaporated from
the container and the test subject
opened his eyes the lead researcher
conducted an immediate interview with
the reassembled subject who reported no
memory of the process after initial
exposure to the blue liquid they
insisted that the process had been like
a good night's sleep which honestly
makes us pretty eager to take it for a
spin a medical examination determined
that there were only a few changes to
the test subject during the disassembly
and reassembly when they returned to
Consciousness the test subject's stomach
was empty the they were naked and all of
their hair was Gone with this new
understanding of scp-291's anomalous
properties the foundation decided to
continue their experimentation with each
new test the experiments became more
creative and unsurprisingly more
depraved first a d-class subject was
placed in the coffin and disassembled
then instead of placing the various body
parts in their designated lockers the
vital organs were removed from their
storage before reassembly was attempted
this resulted in the equipment shutting
down completely a researcher pressed the
third button which forced a hard reset
of the entire process causing all the
blocks of body parts to eject via an
exit hatch during the next experiment
non-vital organs were removed before the
subject's body was reassembled the
appendix and gallbladder were left out
and when the subject regained
Consciousness these organs were still
gone however there was no visible damage
or scar tissue in their place they were
simply gone as if they have never been
there in the the first place so if body
parts could be removed from a test
subject could new body parts be added
could existing body parts be replaced
with different ones a d-class subject in
need of a skin graft following a
flamethrower-based accident was placed
in scp-291 once taken apart a portion of
healthy skin donated by another somewhat
unwilling d-class subject was placed in
the locker along with the skin already
present there once the subject was put
back together the healthy skin had
replaced the damaged skin with no
adverse effects repeat attempts at this
test showed that it was effective for
limb transplants heart transplants and
kidney transplants with a zero percent
failure rate across all tests after
determining that scp-291 could be used
for an Untold amount of good making
organ donations easier and safer than
ever the foundation naturally had to
Pivot to something more useless but
interesting and likely horrifying after
all it's not like they could ever just
make anomalous technology available to
the public right two d-class subjects
one man and one woman were disassembled
by scp-291 the brains of the test
subjects were swapped and then they were
reassembled when they awoke the subjects
had the personalities and memories of
the brain placed in their body in a turn
of events previously only seen in
blockbuster comedies like Freaky Friday
and the live-action Scooby-Doo movie
seminal piece of Cinema the subjects had
swapped bodies they were subsequently
disassembled their request to look at
their new bodies naked having been
swiftly denied and the brains were
returned to their rightful bodies after
the experiment was finished the subjects
appeared mostly normal however they did
complain of disorientation as well as
mental and physical discomfort over the
next several days after going through
two brain transplants in one day though
that's really the least you can expect
after perfecting the practice of
swapping body parts between different
human subjects the ghoulishly Curious
research team decided to take things in
an inter-species Direct action a variety
of test subjects including cats dogs
lizards fish mice and of course humans
were selected for this next round of
experiments 20 tests were performed
using these new subjects and only three
of the experiments were successful in
transferring body parts from an animal
of one species to another animal of a
different one attempts to swap body
parts between mammals and reptiles or
fish proved disastrous when a fish and a
human were both disassembled and the
fish's gills were placed with the
human's body parts neither creature
survived the reassembly process the
human awoke with a new set of gills
embedded in their neck and immediately
began gasping for the oxygen they could
not take in within minutes they had
suffocated the fish's fate was even
worse it did not reassemble so much as
it became a pile of goo scales and two
floating eyeballs experimentation with a
human and a lizard yielded similar
results turning the lizard into a puddle
of organic matter and killing the human
test subject after only a few minutes as
disastrous as the failed cross species
tests were the successful ones were
almost as bad trial 001 involved a cat
and a human not wanting to attempt too
much at once the research team opted to
just swap out one organ the left eye
both subjects survived the transfer and
were able to use their new eye the human
subject reported full use of the cat's
eye with improved night vision in
addition to trouble seeing color the cat
did not enjoy its new eye nearly as much
as the human subject and had clawed its
human eye out of its head by the end of
the following week in trial 007 a
successful brain transfer was performed
between an adult human man and an
English Mastiff the man in the Mastiff's
body expressed discomfort with walking
on all fours and asked to be returned to
his body as soon as possible the mastiff
in the man's body adjusted to bipedal
locomotion in a few hours but was
disassembled after urinating on a
researcher's shoes the final successful
trial and the most unnerving was
trial016 a female d-class test subject's
reproductive organs were swapped with
those of a pregnant Labrador Retriever
an ultrasound conducted after the
transfer indicated that the labrador
fetuses survived the procedure and could
conceivably be carried to term by the
human subject several members of the
research team began to take bets on
whether or not she would end up giving
birth to puppies but the transfer was
reversed within the day so we'll never
know what exactly would have happened
perhaps that's for the best personally
we hope the foundation's Ethics
Committee gives some of these scientists
a very Stern talking to about their
behavior on this one when not in use for
testing
scp-291 is to be disconnected from any
power sources at least two Personnel are
positioned outside of its containment at
all times standing guard and these
personnel must be swapped out every week
when it is not connected to any power
sources scp-291 is considered harmless
though it should still be treated with
caution the main entryway remains closed
and locked when there is no available
power source but the door can be opened
manually from the inside in the event of
an emergency any disassembled organisms
are stored in a locker in the
containment facility labeled with a
sharpie marker in order to keep track of
what specimens are stored there whether
this is the same Sharpie used to label
food in the break room fridge is unknown
but just like Dr D romiro's ham sandwich
it's best to leave these items untouched
any Personnel found to be responsible
for missing specimens will be
transferred to another project and
receive a strongly worded email do you
like scary movies if you're a fan of
horror there have probably been quite a
few times where you found yourself
yelling at the movie screen don't go up
to the attic don't split up don't check
out the noise in the basement run out
the front door you know the characters
can't hear you but when the story is
engaging enough to make you care about
their well-being you can't help but try
and give them a hand after all all you'd
want someone to save you from a machete
wielding Maniac stalking through a
summer camp you took up your new
counselor job at if someone was watching
you hide in the closet listening for a
masked Killer's footsteps with a kitchen
knife in your hand you'd want them to
give you a heads up when the killer was
getting ready to Chomp through the door
with an ax of course the characters in
your favorite movies never listen
because you know that's how movies work
but in 1985 a young man returned a VHS
tape entitled Return of the suburb
slasher to his local video store with a
peculiar complaint the main character of
the movie stopped mid-action to look at
the camera and beg for his help the
video store clerk laughed him off and
refused to give him a refund though he
did eventually give in an offer store
credit after the man began to cry he
decided to take the tape home and watch
it just to see what all the fuss was
about after all he'd never seen someone
cry at a horror movie like that so he
sat down on his favorite beanbag chair
push the tape into the VCR and press
play apparently his shell-shocked
customer had at least remembered to be
kind and Rewind the movie told the story
of Heather Campbell a young woman
planning to host a party at her family's
home in a classic Suburban cul-de-sac
while her parents were out of town an
equally classic slasher fashion this
party would take place on the 10th
anniversary of a series of grisly
murders in the same neighborhood
committed by the mysterious suburb
slasher as the party kicks off with loud
music teenage debauchery and lots of
drinking out of red plastic cups the
killer appears to pick off the group of
friends one by one like other classic
slasher victims your Michaels and your
jasons the suburb slasher also covers
their face wearing a black burlap sack
over their head that masks all
identifiable features the first 90
minutes of the movie were fun but basic
a canoodling couple gets decapitated
here an unnecessary shower scene is cut
short by stamping there the sort of
thing you'd expect but at about 97
minutes in something impossible happened
Heather walked into the living room
finding her friend's dead body strewn
across it and let out a scream that
measured up to the best in the genre the
teen scream Queen then began to run as
the killer appeared to chase her she
made her way into the basement of the
House locked the door behind her then
she turned to the camera Tears In Her
Eyes shirts spattered with blood and
said hey mister I don't know you and I
don't know why you've just sat there
watching this without doing nothing but
please I'm begging you help me out here
what can I do to survive this at first
the clerk thought he was under the
influence of some mind-altering
substance but the only things in his
system were popcorn and store brand soda
now this was really happening he stared
open mouth at the screen where Heather
watched him expectantly he was too
stunned to speak after a moment of
silence Heather's side dejectedly
shaking her head and turned back towards
the stairs she slowly walked back to the
basement door unlocked it and pulled it
open there the killer was waiting with
his expressionless burlap mask the
clerk's eyes widened and he cried out no
but it was too late the film suddenly
cut to Black and with a whirring sound
the VCR spat the tape back out the clerk
sat there staring at the tape what could
he do with it should he make a copy send
it to someone else and pass the curse
along should he try to watch it again he
wasn't sure he could bear to see Heather
looking at him with those same pleading
eyes then he remembered an ad he had
seen in the back of his favorite comic
book seeing something you can explain a
brush with the unknown keeping you up at
night we're looking for stories of the
strange and unusual write to us now
maybe they could do something he
couldn't he put the tank back into its
cover placed it in an envelope and
mailed it off the next day a few days
later the package reached its intended
recipient an undercover branch of the
SCP Foundation tracking anomalous
activity via a series of ads in comic
book and video stores to tap into one of
the most underutilized resource in the
world nerds the tape was designated
scp-5733 and Heather and the mass killer
were designated
scp-5733-2 and
scp-5733-1 respectively after an initial
viewing confirmed its anomalous
properties a research team headed by Dr
Carpenter began to perform a series of
tests testing was open to all Foundation
employees subject to approval by Dr
Carpenter approved Personnel would be
placed in the site-73 multi-purpose room
with a VHS player and a television the
staff member would then watch the movie
and attempt to engage with Heather and
help her Escape for the first test
d-class 1973 was selected when Heather
turned to the camera and asked for help
he asked if she had a car when she
confirmed that yes she did he instructed
her to sneak back upstairs find her car
keys leave through the back door and
drive as fast and as far away as
possible she successfully retrieved the
car key but when she reached the car she
saw that the tires had been slashed
Heather began to panic the 1973 talked
her through it telling her to smash the
window of a neighbor's car and unlock
the door she complied in 1973 instructed
her on how to hotwire the vehicle the
car started and with a triumphant laugh
she sped out of the cul-de-sac just as
her car began to pull away the killer
emerged from the back seat wielding a
kitchen knife Heather screamed and the
tape cut to Black for the next test
d-class 1944 was selected he began by
telling Heather to find her father's
shotgun seen earlier in the film and use
it to take out the killer before they
could get to her she snuck up to her
parents room and found the gun only for
the killer to appear in the doorway
behind her she aimed the gun and fired
but nothing happened the killer opened
their hand dropping the shotgun shells
on the floor she was close but the
killer was one step ahead she screamed
as they approached with a knife and
again the tape cut to Black after
several tests were conducted with
d-class subjects and no adverse effects
were reported aside from the obvious
trauma of failing to save Heather's life
testing was opened up to all Foundation
staff assistant researcher felissa Baker
volunteered she believed her extensive
knowledge of the slasher genre would
give her the tools to help Heather
strategize after speaking with Heather
about her skills which mainly included
party planning and babysitting Felicia
determined that Heather should seek
outside help with Felicia's help Heather
made her way out of the house and over
to the home of her next-door neighbor Mr
Loomis when she got there the door was
open and the lights were off it didn't
look great but she didn't really have
much of a choice but to go inside she
made her way to the bedroom where Mr
Loomis and his wife were lying in bed
she tried to wake him but the camera
zoomed in to reveal his throat had been
slashed the shape in the bed next to him
Sat up and was not in fact his wife but
the suburb slasher instead has the
figure raised their Signature Kitchen
knife the screen went to Black
scp-5733 became a competition of sorts
among Foundation staff each volunteer
proposing their knowledge would help
them get heather to safety assistant
researcher Nick younglin duskowitz
proposed telling Heather to call for
help giving her a secret phone number
for the SCP Foundation Circa 1983 the
time in which the movie was set however
when Heather reached the phone it had
been destroyed smashed to Pieces next to
it was a note written in blood that said
the only foundation here is fear then
the killer appeared behind Heather and
the tape went to Black somehow the
killer knew about the SCP Foundation
perhaps in a manner of speaking the call
was coming from inside the house next
field agent Malcolm Pleasants and Donald
McDowell were selected due to their
extensive knowledge of hand-to-hand
combat they attempted to teach Heather
various fighting and self-defense
techniques while she survived on the
limited supplies available in the
basement she eventually left the
basement and when the killer appeared
began to fight them after 23 minutes of
combat she knocked the slasher to the
floor and grabbed the Candlestick to
finish them off as the agents watching
began to celebrate a second version of
the Suburban slasher appeared behind her
lunging forward just before the new
killer made contact the tape cut to
Black during this test the slasher
seemed more Adept at combat than it had
been before as though it could hear the
advice being given to Heather with other
techniques failing field agent Tilda
Joan Bennett was brought in for a test
selected due to her expertise in
thamaturgy she instructed Heather on
basic offensive and defensive thamaturgy
before guiding her out of the house and
into the front yard when the slasher
appeared brandishing their knife Heather
was able to sign a protective glyph and
defend against the knife's blow she
followed this with a wind spell that
pushed the killer further away Heather
began to run down the driveway making a
break for survival when the slasher
suddenly performed a free spell that
rendered her unable to move Heather's
wide panicked eyes stared down the
barrel of the camera in a Silent Scream
as the killer approached her recovered
the knife in hand before the tape went
to Black eventually Dr Carper
volunteered to conduct a test he
instructed his research team to prepare
a list of options for Heather's survival
divided into four categories what to
take from the basement where to go once
leaving the basement how to exit the
house and how to escape the cul-de-sac
he was not informed about any of these
options but rather had them printed out
and placed into plastic bowls on the day
of the test there were also three cards
created and placed face down reading
Face Body and legs when Heather
addressed Dr Carpenter he informed her
that he would be randomly selecting
instructions for her and asked that she
followed them exactly the first slip of
paper instructed Heather to grab a pair
of garden shears from the basement and
climb the stairs back into the main
house next she was told to go upstairs
to the bedroom then downstairs into the
dining room she complied and there was
no sign of killer so far third Dr
Carpenter told Heather to run back
upstairs out of the bedroom window onto
the roof and then jump down into the
garden then it was time for The Next
Step he told Heather to jump over the
fence into the neighbor's garden and run
down the street until she could find
help as Heather made her way down the
road the slasher broke through the front
door of her house but did not chase
after her Heather continued running down
the road for 20 minutes as the trees and
lights began to dwindle the surroundings
began to grow darker and darker until
they resembled a void Dr Carpenter
instructed her to keep walking she could
make out lights in houses in the
distance she ran toward the neighborhood
but stopped suddenly and began to panic
she was back in her own neighborhood in
front of her own house and the killer
was waiting for her as Heather demanded
to know what to do carpenter flipped
over one of the three cards it read face
and so he told Heather to attack the
Killer's face with the shears then the
Killer's legs then his body the killer
dodged her attack grabbed the shears and
pushed her to the ground has either
looked up at the killer his face could
be seen through the torn sack it was Dr
Carpenter Heather screamed and the tape
cut to Black talk about a third act
twist the movie itself did not create
the killer but somehow the viewer did
and it also made the killer more
creative after this incident all testing
on
scp-5733 was suspended and attempts to
help turn Heather from victim to
Survivor were halted searching for
answers the foundation looked into
Crystal Elms Productions the production
company listed on the videotapes cover
no record of the production company the
film or any of its casts could be found
several months after testing on scp-5733
was suspended another tape was found
because let's face it baby these days
you've gotta have a sequel the new tape
was titled the suburb slasher strikes
again and was purported to be produced
by Crystal Productions in 1985. it was
designated
scp-6733 unlike its predecessor this
tape was only tested once a member of
d-class personnel was first shown
scp-5733 up until the point where it
becomes anomalous and was then shown
scp-6733 he was left completely alone in
order to watch the contents of the tape
the following was what was on it Dr
Malcolm Baines entered the testing
chamber to find Dean 1974 or Jaime
sitting across from the television set
he introduced himself and ran a series
of cognitive tests he asked Jamie what
he thought of the film and he said it
was pretty much your standard slasher
film there's a group of teens who just
graduated high school and go to a local
camping site by a lake to celebrate one
of the mentions that's near the site
where the killer the slasher was shot
dead by police a year prior after a
rampage Dr Baines clarified asking if
this was a reference to the first film
Jaime continued it's not really clear
they all think it's a joke apart from
the main girl she said her dad's a
police officer and she's seen video
evidence of the attack no one references
any of the characters from the first
film though and they don't show up in
this one either the slasher is the only
constant according to Jaime the main
events of the film revolved around a
Lakeside camping trip and quickly began
to go wrong Dr Baines inquired about the
nature of the slasher's kills and Jaime
elaborated he's still got a kitchen
knife same weapon as the first film so
he stabs a lot of them it's pretty Gory
for the time it was made he slashes up
someone's face then the nerdy guy gets
stabbed through the eye that one's
pretty good the camera gets sprayed with
blood one of the teens gets his head
crushed wide open Dr Baines asked Jamie
how the scenes made him feel and he
responded like there's some good jump
scares and the tensions fairly high at
points but that's a little dated I've
seen scarier but I've also seen worse
Horrors only one part of the film stood
out to him he described it so the girl
and her best friend the one that's been
looking out for her this whole time
entered into a Cellar the slasher creeps
up from behind and grabs the friend
tears his head clean off his neck the
slasher then chases the other teen to
the other side of the lake he's
advancing on her the camera set on the
water of the lake it's a wide shot
you've got the lake water line parallel
to the top and bottom of the shot so it
splits the screen horizontally she's
fallen over crawling away from him as he
advances on her the camera Zooms in
slowly though it takes its time and he
does too there's music at the start of
the scene like deep dark synths the stop
says the camera moves closer though I
forgot to say it's a long scene longer
than five minutes maybe it was ten I
don't know it felt longer than 10. so
slasher's approaching her we're the
viewers approaching the shore then the
music stops and it's just his footsteps
and her pleading and she's pleading man
she's there's these big inhales of
breath stifled by the mucus running out
of her nose she's babbling but it gets
to the point she's not even saying words
just making noise as Jaime continued he
began to grow in increasingly distressed
the camera's real close to the shore now
and the slasher stops
he turns his head and looks straight at
the camera you can't see his eyes but
you know he's looking straight at you
and he just stands there staring
eventually the girl crawls out of the
frame or the camera zooms past her I
can't remember which it just keeps
zooming in on his face or his face
should be under the hood the girl keeps
screaming off camera and then there's
this guttural ripping noise and the
screaming stops it just stops but the
camera keeps moving you can see the
individual droplets of blood splashed
across him you can see the Fabrics that
make up his hood his face soon takes up
the entire shot and then black no
credits or nothing the tape just cuts to
Black and was pushed out of the player
Dr Baines pushed a bit asking if there
was anything anomalous he could be
forgetting then Jaime thought of
something the girl her friends all of
them I I don't think they had names
Jaime became increasingly disturbed by
the film over time calling Dr Baines
into his dormitory to ask him if they
had shown him a snuff film after falling
asleep he had a vivid dream of the lake
crawling alongside it recalling the
deaths of his friends at the hand of a
masked killer when he woke up he saw a
Shadow outside the window of his room it
stood there silent and unmoving all
night it only vanished when the sun came
up the next night surveillance caught
the image of a humanoid shape running
through the forest but the guards found
no trace of it Dr Baines returned to
Jamie's cell to find him deeply
distressed he repeated over and over
that the slasher was coming for him Dr
Baines dismissed this concern once Jaime
was alone he stared into the mirror as
the temperature began to drop you're
here aren't you he said a gloved hand
punctured through the mirror spraying
glass everywhere on the other side there
he was the suburb slasher Jaime fled his
dormitory and ran for his life as the
slasher followed him security officer
Lauren confronted the slasher but they
lifted him up by the neck and stabbed
The Familiar kitchen knife through his
head Jaime continued to make his way
through the facility the slasher
following and leaving a trail of
Destruction and bodies in his wake then
he reached Dr Baines who was confused by
his behavior Dr Baines insisted that he
needed to get to the basement but
terrified Jaime resisted him the two men
scuffled and Jaime shoved Dr Bane's hard
sending him careening into the wall a
lighting rig fell from the ceiling
landing on Dr Baines several strangers
ran into the room calling for a medic on
set and asking for production and
lighting to come back and reset
everything off-screen a director yelled
cut the slasher's face appeared taking
up the entirety of the camera and the
tape cut to Black this version of the
tape's events was created after the tape
was watched by d188 in a testing session
with Dr Carpenter there has never been a
Dr Baines in the SCP foundation's
employee somehow this second tape
creates a localized destabilization of
reality it is unknown how many times it
has actually been tested so be careful
what horror rentals you decide to watch
you might just find yourself in the
middle of the action and no matter what
you think you know about surviving a
slasher film there will be no Escape you
can run but you certainly can't hide
okay guys so to wrap this video up I
really don't think this cursed episode
of this show was real it's obviously
just a really good scary fan animation
and the fact that the creators behind it
didn't come out and claim ownership of
it sooner allowing it to be reposted and
re-uploaded so many times is really what
got people thinking was legit that being
said it's still a good attempt at what a
cursed Lost episode would look like so
shout out to those animators man anyway
I've been the goat hellholder 98 be sure
to like this video subscribe to my
channel down below and hey if you know
about any more lost media you want me to
cover leave it in the comments I'll
check it out and be sure to follow my
socials at hellholder98 I go live most
days and post updates about new videos
on my story so go check it out alright
until then I'll see you somewhere down
the line the moment his finger pushed
the button to stop the camera recording
the practiced false smile dropped from
Holden's face it was hard not to feel
down after he'd finished filming a new
video not thanks to any post-creativity
slump but the more depressing knowledge
of just how much of an uphill battle
this whole thing was it felt like
yesterday when Holden had first gotten
into the creepier side of the internet
he never ventured into anything illicit
or outright illegal mind you but there
was a distinct corner of the web that
had pulled him in when he was still at
school and just starting to spend more
time online this part of the internet
was filled with scary stories that were
mostly fake or made up for likes but
that could have been real there were
unsettling animations short clips that
were hand drawn to give people the
creeps and keep them up at night not to
mention a whole Archive of Public Safety
announcement videos terrifying workplace
and road safety warnings that used to be
brought us on TV and were as petrifying
than the most acclaimed horror movies
speaking of things that were broadcast
to TV that had gradually become Holden's
specialty one of his friends had sent
him the link to a fictional account of
someone who had supposedly uncovered an
unaired episode of a Saturday morning
kids cartoon or so this person claimed
anyway they went on to describe bizarre
imagery so intense and terrifying that
it was unbefitting of a show for
children then the person who made the
original post explained how they got
into contact with the show's creators
via email to ask them about this cursed
episode The showrunner responded stating
that the episode the poster had
allegedly seen didn't even exist to
Holden it didn't matter if the story was
real or not that wasn't the point what
was far more important was that it felt
real to him it was plausible even
possible that there were pieces of media
out there in the world that had never
seen the light of day episodes of TV
shows or entire movies that were so wild
and out there but they could have been
banned and buried long before the dawn
of the internet wherein there was a
record of everything and nothing was
ever really lost the idea of uncovering
those lost pieces of media became
Holden's primary hobby he'd come home
from school throw his backpack onto his
bed and then sit in front of his
computer for hours without even changing
out of the clothes he had been wearing
all day in class but all the time he
spent trawling through form threads
following and messaging collectors on
social media listening to theories and
coming up with his own eventually it
began to encroach on other things much
to his mom's disappointment Holden's
grades took a rapid decline it wasn't
long before he was failing his classes
bad enough to not make the cut to
continue on at school but as much as it
upset his mother Holden really didn't
mind he was already thinking Way Beyond
high school and he knew he didn't need
grades to be able to do the one thing he
wanted to do life Holden set up his own
Channel with the plan to start uploading
videos under his new online alter ego
and before long hell holder 98 was born
he centered his whole internet Persona
around lost media discussing which
popular rumors were true and which were
fictionalized for likes and clicks it
started out with a few discussion videos
where he would simply sit in his bedroom
a camcorder opposite to him as he spoke
but before long Holden was adding more
and more Flair to his content learning
how to edit on his computer adding Clips
or screenshots he could find of supposed
Lost TV episodes to give his videos some
credibility a very necessary quality
when trying to determine if certain
things were real or not each video he
finished he had another two topics to a
list of ideas he kept planning to just
perpetually churn out content until he
eventually had a huge hit that went
viral although the one thing he didn't
realize until it was perhaps too late
was that social media success didn't
happen overnight in fact it didn't
happen over many many nights either no
matter how often Holden promoted his
channel on his social media profiles or
how many new videos he uploaded he
couldn't seem to get any to land well
and get boosted by the algorithm at
least that's one of the things he
attributed the problem to he pointed the
finger of blame at anything that he
could one day it was that the algorithm
was suppressing his channel and boosting
others who had already got more
subscribers the next it might be his
slow internet connection had led to one
of his videos going live at a time when
the site had low traffic the one
possibility that Holden didn't stop to
consider was that maybe his genre of
content was too Niche but that the days
of the internet's interest in Lost media
had already peaked back when he was
still in high school nevertheless he
kept trying making content day in and
day out working under the assumption
that if he just made enough videos then
one day he was sure to blow up that
would be his big break his ultimate win
a video that did well enough to 100
thousands if not millions of views but
the more time he devoted to Hell holder
98 the only number that seemed to be at
all increasing was the number of videos
he had posted each one barely garnering
view figures that were above a single
digit to make matters worse getting help
with growing his online brand was next
to Impossible every now and then he
would post on forms asking for advice or
if anyone wanted to collaborate so he
could gain some exposure from creators
with bigger followings those posts were
often met with a slew of apathetic snide
responses or comments telling Holden 2
just quote make better content as if
that was solid specific advice on top of
that his mom had outright refused to
support her son's chosen career path
citing his failure at school as the main
reason speaking of any friends Holden
previously had at school had all moved
away in the years since going off to
pursue college and other higher
education some were even starting their
new and exciting professions the old
saying said it's Lonely at the Top but
hold and was just as lonely down at the
bottom posting his content in total
obscurity as if he was just shouting
into an empty void with no one around to
hear the few people Holden did still
consider his friends were all as
chronically online as he was most of
them fellow lost media collectors after
interacting with them in the common
threads of various forums a handful of
like-minded guys were as close as Holden
had to people actively supporting his
channel the collectors would usually
give him pointers or topics to discuss
in videos and contributing to the single
digit view count underneath his uploads
although to him it wasn't nearly enough
he didn't want just his friends to see
his videos he wanted an audience a fan
base of his own it was late the light of
the computer monitor Illuminating the
dark of Holden's bedroom hunched over
his desk he was clicking and dragging
clips into the timeline of a video
project trimming them down to make the
whole thing better paced snipping out
bad takes where he stumbled over his
words or misspoke it was while editing
that Holden noticed another screen
lighting up on his desk accompanied by a
vibration his phone he reached for it
seeing a notification popped up on the
lock screen it was from gov one of the
Lost media collectors and it read dude
urgent found something that you can make
a video on hold inside it was late and
he was already focused on editing this
current video tonight if you got it
finished then he could go to sleep what
do you know about the deathly videotape
goeth asked in a second message before
Holden even had a chance to open it
first the what he replied bluntly before
sending another text saying can't this
wait until the morning I'm trying to
edit if you don't act fast it'll be gone
forever came the response only a second
later followed by a link lethargically
hold and tapped the hyperlink oath had
sent his phone opening up its browser
and displaying the web page it was a buy
and sell website one of those places
where people offloaded junk they didn't
want anymore to strangers for a bit of
extra cash the page in question showed a
few grainy photos taken on on a phone of
a small rectangular object in someone's
hand what is that Holden asked it's a
videotape bonehead both fired back
although they'd never met in person
Holden always got the sense his friend
was a little older than he was looking
back on the seller's ad it was for a
secondhand Sony color collection 60 to
90 minute mini DV videotape a type of
cassette used in a lot of old handheld
recording cameras so what holdenast in
another text look there have been rumors
for Aegis about something called The
Deathly videotape growth replied in a
series of Rapid Fire messages it used to
be all the rage on a lot of old lost
media forums the real nasty ones before
they got shut down supposedly there's a
recording on this tape of some kind of
live show except when you put in your
VCR and press play you see something
horrible nobody even knows if it's real
or just a legend how do you know this is
the same tape Holden queried by now he
had typed out the same link on his
computer and was looking at the for sale
page on the bigger screen while he
texted back and forth with both read the
item description he answered Holden's
eyes scan down the page finding a short
message from the seller to anyone
interested I'm giving this old Mini DV
tape away I don't know where I got it or
why I watched it but I wish I hadn't it
had ruined everything for me it's
impossible to enjoy anything else now
that I've seen what's on it let me make
this clear I am not selling this tape
I'm giving it away free of charge I hope
that getting rid of it will help sounds
ominous holding texted if you're so sure
if this is the deathly videotape then
why don't you get it keep reading growth
responded underneath the item
description was another note that the
seller had written please note I am
unable to leave my town at present nor
can I mail this tape to anyone even if
you pay postage collection only if
you're interested please contact me at
the following address below was an
address it was in Holden's Hometown only
a few streets away from where he and his
mom lived this could be it dude came
another slew of messages from gov you
buy this tape and make a video recording
then you might finally go viral but you
better be quick before someone goes and
picks it up thinking it's just an
ordinary tape Holden looks back at the
address double checking where it was at
most it'd take a quick walk there and
back he thought and if this tape was as
elusive as ghost said it was then owning
it would mean Holden would be the only
one who could make a video featuring it
after messaging the seller the night
before Holden found himself rushing
through his quiet neighborhood to the
address all night as he tried to sleep
he kept thinking of the video he was
going to make how he could finally put
him on the map and at long last bring
him the e-fame he'd been working towards
wrapping his knuckles against the front
door he was met by an older man who
stood on the other side he was walking
with a crutch with a few bruises and
stitched up cuts on his face the second
that Holden explained he was there for
the tape the man reached to an unseen
shelf just inside the door frame and
thrust the rectangular cassette into his
hands before shutting the door as
quickly as he could without it hitting
Holden Square in the face he stared at
the tape in his hands though through its
transparent green plastic case he could
see a hand scrawled note I know you'll
ignore me if I tell you not to watch
this it read so if you do then on your
own head be it having spent the rest of
the day looking up exactly what he'd
need to play such an old out modded
recording format and convert the footage
to digital so he could include it in his
video Holden had retrieved his mom's old
VHS player from the attic wiping the
thick layer of dust off of it it took a
while for him to get everything ready to
go not just finding the right adapters
and cables to hook the VCR up to his TV
as well as linking that to his computer
plus angling his camera right and making
sure the ring light he bought for
filming was putting enough focus on his
face after the substantial prep Holden
took a deep breath summoning up the faux
excitement and Stage smile before he hit
the record button on his camera what's
up guys it's hell holder98 here now
today I've got a real treat for you all
so my friend goth shout out to him told
me that a while ago there was talk about
something called the deathly videotape
we found a mini DV tape that we think
might be that very same tape so we're
gonna watch it and see if it's legit
dropping his Persona as his face turned
away from the camera Holden punched the
play button on the VHS player his eyes
glued to the TV screen as the camera's
lens was fixated on him okay nothing so
far he observed met with nothing but a
blank black screen suddenly after 12
seconds of nothing the playback started
instantly and Holden started relaying
what he was seeing on the tape to the
camera there was no sound either because
the recording on the videotape was
filmed that way or Holden hadn't
properly figured out how to hook it up
to the VHS the video itself showed a
recording of Sesame Street Live and for
the most part just seemed pretty
underwhelming characters were up on
stage their puppeteers managing to stay
out of sight as they entertained their
young audience after two and a half
minutes Holden was starting to feel like
he'd gone to all this effort over what
seemed to just be someone's old unwanted
home video just as he was considered
during turning off the camera and
throwing the videotape in the trash at
almost the three minute Mark something
weird started happening on the stage the
actor playing one of the bigger
characters seemed to be having some
trouble instantly trying to pull off his
cumbersome costume much to the distress
of the kids in the audience looking on
in horror but it wasn't just the
illusion that had been broken the actor
was trying to get out of his costume
because he was choking he dropped to his
knees on stage clawing at his own throat
before Finally Falling face down totally
still asphyxiated dead over the next
almost 20 seconds the same thing started
happening to another three of the
characters on stage all of them
violently choking while the children in
the audience screamed and cried silently
on the inaudible tape then at three and
a half minutes the video cut out Holden
was unsure how to react at first a
little creeped out only to be somewhat
bemused he played it down for the camera
remarking that the video seemed tame
compared to some of a more graphic fake
content he'd seen but the whole time
even after rapping recording sitting
awake all night to edit his reaction
video blurring out the parts that would
break the terms of service he had no
idea what he'd seen was actually real or
not finishing the final edit just as the
sun was coming up Holden hit upload and
crawled into bed while his video was
uploaded the buzz of a text message from
goth awoke him dude I told you this
video was going to make it big without
even replying Holden booted up his
computer and opened the page for his
newly uploaded video The View count was
already in the thousands and climbing
comments pouring in underneath mostly
from people debating whether or not the
contents of the tape had been faked
Holden punched the air and excitement
he'd finally done it but as the video
kept playing he heard a wretching sound
coming from the computer's speakers he
turned to look back at his earlier self
filmed only the night before except what
he was seeing play out on screen now
wasn't what he remembered happening last
night it couldn't have because the
Holden in that video was choking that
wasn't possible he was alive and
watching his own video right now but
somehow the footage was shown him dying
his Airway blocked face turning red then
blue was tears streamed down his cheeks
in the video hell holder 98 fell down
dead from asphyxiation and watching it
made Holden feel sick to make matters
worse none of the comments under the
video seemed to have witnessed the same
ending Holden even texts goeth to ask if
the same thing had happened but he
described the ending exactly as Holden
remembered filming it but afterwards it
didn't stop happening everything he
watched ended the same every clip online
every TV show every movie Holden
couldn't even read a book without some
characters fictional or otherwise
Keeling over and choking to death just
like the characters on the tape he
barely had time to acknowledge the hits
his reaction to the deathly videotape
we're getting he was too busy trying to
figure out why he couldn't stop seeing
people dying the exact same way even
himself self when he watched back his
old hellholder 98 videos reacting to the
deathly videotape garnered a respectable
3 million views but hellholder 98 never
uploaded again afterwards his channel
went silent remembered only as a one-hit
wonder until the video and the entire
Channel were taken down Holden was never
reported missing the foundation made
sure of that when they came by to
collect scp-583 and place the videotape
into containment we've covered a lot of
scps on this channel but trust us none
of them have quite the bite that this
one does we know you like the more
intellectual anomalies and this will
give you plenty to chew on in that
regard while the SCP Foundation wants to
keep
scp-5940 a secret here at SCP explained
we're gonna give you the tooth the whole
tooth and nothing but the tooth
uh truth I meant truth this SCP
thankfully isn't as existentially
threatening as a lot of the other ones
we cover but just because it won't send
you on an Express trip to the Pearly
Gates doesn't mean it won't wreak havoc
on your pearly whites open wide and say
ah because today we're getting into an
anomaly that affects each and every one
of us tell us have you ever felt anxious
about your teeth ever had that weird
dream where all your teeth fall out or
even worse someone pulls them out does
the thought of us taking a hammer to
your teeth throw them rotting away
someday and making you need dentures
make you shudder and cringe don't be
ashamed the answer to this question for
most people would be a resounding yes
and that's because of Humanity's shared
psychodental trauma don't know what that
is oh that's fine too after all the
foundation has taken pains to hide all
this from you for fear that even knowing
about it might incur further psycho
Dental stress it's that kind of subtle
but constant creeping dread you
experience in a dentist's waiting room
knowing it's been too long since the
last time you came in and now you're
fully anticipating him saying something
like well it's a real mess in here I'm
afraid we're gonna have to take them all
and I'm gonna charge you double just
because they they look so unpleasant if
that feels grimly familiar to you then
you know exactly what we're talking
about today the SCP Foundation searched
long and hard to find the source of this
peculiar Collective trauma which
ironically is a major factor in people
not actually visiting the dentist more
often and has found the source in
question to be as ancient as it is
strange to best explain exactly what
we're dealing with here we need to take
a trip to the North Pole though sorry to
tell you that today's SCP is not in fact
Santa's Workshop it's actually the
northernmost point of inaccessibility a
part of the world that's nearly
impossible to reach simply by virtue of
being the cluster of Arctic ice pack
furthest away from any land mass always
moving and shifting but if through some
means you were ever able to make your
way up there you would find an
impossibly large pair of maxillary
incisors which in layman's terms is a
giant pair of front teeth so while there
may not be Santa's ground Auto up there
if all you want for Christmas is your
two front teeth then buddy you're in
luck incidentally these two giant teeth
embedded into the ground and dubbed
scp-5940 by the SCP Foundation are
connected to the two front teeth of
every human being on Earth think of it
as almost a pair of giant voodoo dolls
but their effects on each individual
human are relatively mild that's because
the effects are actually distributed
across all humans and the more humans
there are the less damage to the
enormous pair of teeth will affect each
of us the problem is humans have eight
incisors they're the two sets of four
front teeth on the upper and lower jaw
and this pair of teeth covers only two
of them what about the rest well next on
our roster is
scp-5940-2 let's join Intrepid scientist
and explore Dr John E namel who has no
affiliation with the SCP Foundation on
his quest to find them Dr enamel and his
small team Brave brutal colds and
obscene tracks through ice and know to
finally discover this Grand creation
near the southern pole of
inaccessibility the point of Antarctica
furthest away from the Southern Ocean
when he and his men finally arrived they
gazed upon the incredible pair of teeth
in awe a mighty set of mandibular
Central incisors otherwise known as the
front teeth on the bottom jaw the
foundation believes that the only way to
truly solve the problems that scp-5940
poses is to remove the various teeth
from the areas where they're currently
lodged however the foundation doesn't
yet possess the technology or resources
to properly dislodge any of these
behemoths however the psychic
anticipation of the impending tooth
removal has caused the psychodental
trauma of people all over the world to
Skyrocket in the meantime in a sense
it's like the entire world is sitting
outside the dentist's office waiting for
a prognosis and hoping that when the
dentist pulls out their pair of surgical
pliers they at least have the decency to
give us a hit of the laughing gas first
however the foundation has discovered an
interesting in fact in the meantime the
effects of the teeth on the global
population can be slightly mitigated by
enacting certain forms of concussive
trauma on them and to perform this act
for the greater good of the Earth's
psychodental condition Dr John E enamel
and those accompanying him made the
ultimate sacrifice knowing on a
subconscious level what they must do
they began to turn their equipment into
a kind of makeshift diving board above
the giant incisors once the board was
complete the adventurist each took turns
jumping off of it gaining speed as they
rocketed down towards the teeth below as
each of them hit the sharp upper edges
of the teeth they were cut in half
leaving a smear of red Against The
Shining white calcium the two halves of
their bisected bodies fell down into the
piles of Frozen Bones on either side of
the teeth space all that remained of
Prior Brave Heroes who'd made their
final pilgrimage to the site of
scp-5940 while none of these various
Expeditions were in any way officially
related to the SCP Foundation the
foundation nonetheless extended honorary
Foundation stats of Mira to those who
decided to take the plunge for the
collective psychodental health of their
fellow man for
scp-5940-3 we have to go deeper
literally it's at the bottom of the
ocean namely it sits below Point Nemo
also known as the oceanic point of
inaccessibility the furthest point away
from land in the entire world's oceans
this next absurd pair of teeth some
mandibular lateral incisors lurk below
the churning ocean waves like uh well
there's nothing really like a giant pair
of underwater teeth is there thankfully
the position of these teeth have been
serendipitous not only does their
remoteness make them much harder for
civilians to just stumble upon but Point
Nemo has always been a popular
spacecraft graveyard this means that
during tests and sometimes even actual
missions the return trips are often
piloted towards Point Nemo to prevent
the risk of any air and spacecraft
pieces from Landing in populated areas
and causing damage or death remember we
mentioned earlier that the foundation
encourages repeated concussive attacks
against the teeth to ward off their
psychodental effects here the pieces of
spacecraft blasting into the water
towards them fulfill that role at the
latest measurement 126 of the 263
spacecraft ditched at this pole since
1971 had successfully collided with this
particular pair of teeth giving them
perhaps the weakest output of
psychodontal trauma of any of the
scp-5940 instances and while the
furthest point in the ocean from any
major land masses may seem about as
remote As It Gets the last instance of
scp-5940 easily blows it out of the
water well not literally but if it did
that would be a wonderful example of a
problem taking care of itself wouldn't
it the last instance of
scp-5940
scp-5940-4 a pair of maxillary lateral
incisors Live On the Dark Side of the
Moon yep dentists and Pink Floyd fans of
the world Rejoice you're probably
wondering while the first three pairs of
teeth clearly grew on Earth why is the
fourth a pair of more lunar incisors
studies performed by the foundation on
the soil around the base of the fourth
set of teeth proved that they actually
did originate on Earth they believed to
have split from Earth during the
incident which formed the moon this
means that these teeth are literally
older than the moon and this also makes
them billions of years older than
Humanity so these giant teeth don't look
like are incisors are incisors look like
these giant teeth so now we finally
understand this ridiculous threat to our
Collective psychodental Health move over
scp-682 and step aside devour of Worlds
get the hell out of my face Scarlet King
we can't deal with any of you small
timers until we solve the global
psychodental Health crisis posed by
scp-5940 which Elite Heavy Hitters have
the foundation put on the case to deal
with these enamel nightmares meet the
department of psychodentistry a joint
venture formed from the collaboration of
of the psionics division a task force
that specializes in psyche scps the
department of memetics and most
importantly of all the Dentistry
division you may be thinking why does
the SCP Foundation even need a Dentistry
division that seems like a waste of time
and resources and if you're thinking
that you're not only wrong you probably
have horrible teeth the Dentistry
division is the first and last line of
defense that the foundation has against
a plethora of toothy anomalies like
scp-5852 a strange phenomenon that
causes human teeth to grow out of the
bodies of cicadas or scp-2450 a
condition that causes hyperdontia the
excessive development of teeth all over
the bodies of mammalian creatures with
the infection being spread appropriately
through bites and of course
scp-478 a predatory moth-like creature
that enters the bodies of victims under
the age of 25 and attaches itself to the
soft palate in the upper nasal cavity
from there it would promote the
unchecked growth of teeth on the soft
palate of the victim but that's just
where it starts teeth develop all
throughout the mouth nasal cavity
esophagus and even the interior of the
stomach where the digestion of the teeth
leads to excruciating pain next time
your entire body is filling up with
teeth due to scp-478 you'll really
regret underestimating the value of the
humble Dentistry division so what does
the new Department of psychodentistry
propose to do with scp-5940 the ultimate
in tooth-based anomalies thankfully they
have a plan that will unfold over the
next 79 years known as the absolute
tooth field in all uppercase letters
it's a three-pronged plan that's sure to
fully neutralize this Dental Menace you
see there's one thing we haven't told
you the psionic relationship between
scp-5940 and the incisors of all of
humanity isn't one way while the giant
teeth and what happens to them can
affect our teeth what happens to our
teeth can also affect the nature of
scp-5940 and that little fact is the key
to the absolute tooth field plan the
first part of the plan involves using
mimetics to make humans shun birth
control globally accelerating population
growth to 4.2 percent per year for the
next 79 years this will lead to a
population of 200 billion humans by the
year 2100. the second part will be using
memetics to encourage every human to
somehow mechanically remove all of their
incisors and the third part will be the
most complicated of all trying to get
all these 200 billion humans to remove
the same incisors at the same time the
department of psycho Dentistry estimates
that this will create the sufficient
psychic Force to finally pull the
various scp-5940 instances from their
Moorings and thus healing Humanity's
Collective psychodental trauma it is a
brilliant plan to take out a dangerous
anomaly and surely one trillion 600
billion human incisors is a small price
to pay in the summer of 2007 in the
heart of a forest in Northern California
hundreds of people were gathered for a
yearly art and music festival it was
meant to be a celebration a weekend
filled with creative expression dancing
and sure probably some illegal
substances but it was all said to be a
mostly wholesome Affair and one that
attendees had been looking forward to
all year on the evening of the
festival's first night after a day of
painting performance art interpretive
dance and folk pop Fusion the organizers
put together a massive bonfire everyone
gathered around roasting marshmallows
and vegan hot dogs and breaking out
their acoustic guitars for a sing-along
it was all going well and they were
heading into the third refrain of
Kumbaya when a group of friends adding
logs to the fire noticed something odd
some of the Flames at the edge of the
fire pit were moving in a different
direction than the rest while most of
the Flames flickered upward some tilting
slightly with the direction of the wind
these Flames were moving sideways
Against the Wind
stretching themselves out towards the
grass it seemed bizarre impossible and
they wondered at first if perhaps the
brownies they had eaten earlier had more
than just chocolate in them but then the
Flames kept moving taking on a familiar
shape they were dancing orange and
yellow flames there was no doubt about
that but they also seemed almost like
fingers the fingers extended outward
grasping for something attached to the
fingers was a hand then an arm another
hand joined it twisting into the grass
which dried and crackled at its touch
one of the friends a young woman named
flower attempted to alert one of the
event staff but they were too busy
trying to get their marshmallow to the
perfect shade of golden brown unable to
get any help she watched helplessly as
the fiery hands dragged ahead a torso
and the rest of a humanoid body behind
them it looked like the shape of an
ordinary man with the glaring exception
that it was made entire entirely out of
fire it stepped out of the fire pit and
began to take slow halting strides
toward the gathered crowd now everyone
took notice of what was happening first
they froze in shock staring at this
being of pure flame unbearable heat
right off of him as he moved closer and
closer when he reached out a hand toward
flower and the arm of flowers dress
ignited in flames on contact the first
scream broke through the silence when
they marketed this year's event as
Burning Man in the woods this was not
what they had in mind but there he was
just the same a man made of flames
tearing through what was meant to be a
peaceful and happy event with no dangers
Beyond exhaustion dehydration and maybe
a noise complainer too instead the crowd
scattered in every possible Direction
running for their lives it was already
too late for poor flower who fell to the
ground shrieking in agony as the fire
engulfed the organic material of her
dress and the flame man pulled her into
its deadly arms her screams went quiet
drowned out by the crackling Roar of the
fire as it fed on her flammable body
once flower was nothing but a pile of
bones and Ashes The Entity began to walk
slowly purposefully through the woods
with its arms outstretched it brushed
its fingertips over everything it passed
every tree every stump every plant or
scrap of fabric torn off of a branch the
fire began to spread like well Wildfire
by the time the first Festival goers
made it out of the forest and into the
nearby town to get help dozens of Acres
of forest were Ablaze and over 50 people
were dead the fire department was
deployed to the forest where they were
able to contain the blaze after hours of
work meanwhile word of the man made a
fire that destroyed the art and music
festival reached the only people
qualified to deal with such a creature
the SCP Foundation they deployed
operatives embedded in the local police
force who joined the fire department
under the guise of providing
reinforcements once the blaze was
contained and the area was largely safe
to enter they followed the path of the
fire and tracked the being responsible
for all of the destruction they found it
shrunk to the size of a small child
huddled in the fire pit where it all
began as if it was hiding from the fire
hoses then they apprehended the being
later designated
scp-457
scp-457 is comprised of unknown
materials though obviously it is made up
of something flammable whatever it is it
is made up of something invisible and
impossible to detect by any known
scientific means the only visible aspect
of the entity is the Flames it produces
which tend to make up a humanoid shape
as long as it has enough fuel to reach
that size if it does not have enough
fuel it shrinks in size becoming as
small as the single flame atop a lit
match in its smallest form it is
indistinguishable from any other small
flame except for the occasional display
of Independence such as jumping to other
fires or flammable materials which you
can then use to grow larger when it is
large enough to take on a human form
scp-457 displays human-like intelligence
and is capable of communication through
writing which it does by burning letters
into surfaces with its Flames or even
through speech though it lacks the
anatomy to produce a traditional voice
it produces coherent sounds via
pressurized superheated air as well as
the crackle of its Flames if provided
with enough fuel to grow Beyond humanoid
size The Entity can split into two or
more beings depending on how much fuel
it is given however this split state
does not last as the separate instances
of scp-457 will attempt to attack each
other until they are the only one left
standing
scp-457 seems to want nothing more than
to consume more and more fuel and spread
as far as it can it has shown a
troubling ability to learn and adapt
purposefully breaking and interfering
with sprinkler systems in the building
and setting up elaborate traps for
personnel it does not like Dr Smythe
head of the research team assigned to
scp-457 conducted an interview with the
subject on a rare day where it was
feeling Cooperative in order to better
assess its psychology and motivations Dr
Smythe entered scp-457's containment
chamber carrying a fire extinguisher in
case of any hostility on the part of the
entity he stood on the other side of the
blast shielded window for Extra
Protection it crackled pleasantly in the
corner seeming to welcome him inside he
asked if it was capable of or willing to
speak it answered yes he asked how it
felt about being confined it responded
plainly dislike no fuel no air when Dr
Smythe reminded The Entity that it had
enough air and fuel to survive it argued
that it could not burn and had no fuel
to clarify Dr Smith asked are you saying
that you cannot grow at this question
scp-457 moved back and forth through the
small section of the room as if pacing
and looking for something it said grow
need must grow and when asked how it
felt it simply said hungry as the
questioning continued The Entity
approached the window and stretched a
hand made a flame toward the glass for a
moment it stopped responding to Dr
Smythe in order to get the beings
attention back he casually brought up
the subject of water at the very mention
of it
scp-457 let out a high-pitched scream
and pressed itself against the window in
a threatening gesture Dr Smith warned it
that it must move away from the window
or it would be doused in water it moved
back but screamed and hissed for several
more minutes offended and upset
scp-457 resumed its pacing at a more
aggressive speed and intensity all the
while it repeated one fuel want air want
burn want burn want to burn again and
again getting louder and louder as it
moved Dr Smythe was perplexed by this
Behavior noting that there was no way
out and wondering what it could be
trying to accomplish at this point the
interview took a turn for the disastrous
somehow scp-457 was able to damage the
sprinkler system and a section of the
fuel injector that had been providing it
with a small stream of fuel with the
nozzle broken open several gallons of
gasoline came flooding out allowing The
Entity to grow to an incredible size in
the sudden massive destructive blast
exploiting a weakness in the blast
shielding scp-457 was able to escape its
containment for several minutes burning
its way down the hall of the facility
until the larger sprinkler system
activated sending it hissing back to its
cell there it was apprehended by a team
of guards and herded into a new higher
security cell it is unknown how exactly
the entity became aware of the
weaknesses in its containment chamber
but this incident revealed that it is a
highly intelligent being capable problem
solving however it learned this
information and figured out how to
exploit it the foundation realized that
more extensive measures would need to be
taken to keep it locked down and keep
the general population safe due to the
dangerous nature of scp-457's corporeal
form highly specialized containment
procedures have been put in place to
keep the flame from spreading the entity
is kept in a five by five meter chamber
with at least nine inches of
fireproofing in place including Asbestos
and perlite the observation window is
blast proof and resistant to extremely
high temperatures the room's opening is
made up of temperature controlled and
airtight chambers that can be sealed in
the event of an escape attempt the room
itself is kept at a high humidity level
and a drain has been installed on the
floor with a sprinkler system in the
ceiling and emergency hoses that can be
operated if additional water is needed a
small portion of the room is free from
water but only enough so that scp-457
can maintain its shape and protect
itself from moisture sure any Personnel
that enters
scp-457's containment unit must wear
Class A temperature-controlled and flame
resistant suits and must enter in groups
of three two of the three members of
each group must be armed with blast
Shields and fire extinguishers Personnel
are not permitted to enter the
containment chamber for any reason other
than providing daily fuel or fixing any
issues with the room or its sprinkler
system in some ways its containment
procedures are reminiscent of a
particularly spicy variant of
SCP-173 if the entity attempts to attack
any Personnel it can be deterred via the
application of fire extinguishers or
hoses until it backs down if it escapes
from containment further sprinkler
systems will be activated throughout the
facility in order to contain the fire
the highest priority aside from keeping
the entity contained is keeping it fed
because it needs constant fuel in order
to survive the foundation is currently
prioritizing finding an infinitely
renewable source of fuel though many
have been proposed including the use of
other scps such as
scp-2689 and scp-124 no Source has been
officially approved yet in the meantime
they keep the burning being fed and
happy or as happy as it can be it will
never be truly satisfied until a day
arrives where it can be permitted to
spread as far and wide as it wishes to
burn and feed and engulf everything in
sight let's hope that day never comes
but if you start to feel unusually hot
if the walls seem too suddenly blacken
around you and you hear the final
crackles before the hissing tongues of
flame look at your bubbling skin well by
that point it'll already be too late in
1961 the SCP Foundation discovered a
town that was completely devoid of all
life not long before their arrival
Darrington North Carolina had been a
community with high aspirations a deeply
religious Township of devout Christians
many of whom were seeking greater
prosperity from their lives but now
their home was a ghost town with no sign
of any prior Darrington resident to be
found where in the hell had they all
gone it oddly seemed like the population
of an entire town would all
simultaneously decide to up sticks and
leave two pastors new but then again
maybe the citizens of Darrington hadn't
left at all perhaps they weren't even
really still human and had taken up
residence somewhere much darker like
underground this is the story of one of
the earliest known instances of a
phenomenon now known under the
designation of
scp-3089 or to use its alternative name
that old-time religion when the SCP
Foundation arrived in a desolate
Darrington to find the townsfolk had all
vanished they immediately began an
investigation into the exact house and
whys the answers to what exactly had
happened here after all while not a huge
Place Darrington was home to nearly a
1000 residents and that many people
don't just disappear if they even had
disappeared and weren't just dormant but
what the foundation uncovered was a
gruesome discovery that led them to not
only demolishing the entire North
Carolinian town but purchasing all the
land around it to keep the area under
permanent observation prior to the
demolition however the ministry of
Sevenfold blessing had been one of the
oldest buildings in Darrington much like
most Town churches and it was while
searching the offices of this church
that the foundation cleanup Crews
discovered their first piece of evidence
the initial clue about what had happened
to this deserted town they recovered a
series of cassette tapes each with a
recording of sermons that had been given
within the ministry of Sevenfold
blessing these were all delivered by One
Pastor Bartholomew Jenner the first
having been recorded on August 17th of
1959 two years earlier my friends I want
to talk to you about what the Bible
offers tonight Pastor Jenner began in
the first of these recordings I want to
talk to you about what you are owed I
want to talk to you about I want to talk
to those of you who are struggling right
now to those of you who have hardship
and pain maybe you've heard that the
Bible only nourishes the spirit that God
only provides for our Immortal Souls
well my friends I'm here to tell you
that this is simply not true Pastor
Bartholomew Jenner seemed to be focused
on the discussion of very real relatable
problems after all what person hasn't
felt unsatisfied with their life at one
point or another and this was apparently
no different for the people of
Darrington many of you can think of
places in your lives where you have not
yet risen where you are not yet
Victorious marriage finances hell but do
not fret my friends God wants you to
rise he has cleared a path for you it is
one littered with his Earthly Treasures
to claim them you only need to shed your
old elves and be reborn the bastard was
merely using the shared faith of the
township to help reaffirm that their
struggles were not the be-all and all of
their lives or at least that's how it
first appeared but the religious
practices taking place in this first
recording would soon take a bizarre turn
making it clear there was something far
more Sinister even cult-like going on in
the ministry of seventh-fold blessing
now if you would some of the ladies from
the mayor's office were kind enough to
collect these cicada shales pass along
each of you take one yes the children
too be careful very careful they are
fragile each of you take one and hold it
in your left hand yes the left hand not
the right your left the shells of dead
cicadas hardly seen like common fare for
a sermon like this although as the
recording continued it was easy to
understand that Pastor Jenner intended
these discarded insect carapaces to be
something of a metaphor even if they
were pretty gross especially to some
with the younger members of his
congregation he explained to the
Darrington residents that these cicada
shells Were Meant To Be symbolic of
whatever hardship the citizens were
currently struggling with in their lives
whether it was work a marriage or an ill
family member then came the next part of
this unorthodox practice the pastor
instructed everyone in the congregation
to picture themselves holding their
biggest problem in their left hand now I
want you to squeeze your left hand
squeeze it into a fist feel that problem
cracking like old dried out paper fill
it crumbled to dust Jenner told them the
residents of Darrington did so crushing
the cicada shells until there was
nothing left everyone open your eyes
don't you feel better stronger this is
what is offered our hardships are like
the shell we shall cast them aside even
as they crumble God has cleared a path
needless to say the foundation agents
that recovered the tapes of Pastor
Jenner's odd sermons weren't exactly
sure what to make of them and as unusual
as they were the recordings did little
to indicate where the townspeople of
Darrington North Carolina had
disappeared to but as they listened
further what they found was even more
unsettling than an entire Congregation
of people crushing cicada shells in the
second recording dated December 19th of
1959 Pastor Jenner was once again
presiding over his congregation he had
just finished quoting a passage from
Matthew chapter 25 verse 30 which
related to a Biblical tale known as the
parable of the talents in this story a
master puts his servants in charge of a
differently sized portion of his wealth
while he is away then judges them based
on whether or not his servants make a
profit using his money the third servant
who had received the least talents
meaning an amount of money was punished
for burying his share in the ground cast
out into the outer Darkness to face
weeping and gnashing of teeth it was
after making mention of this
unprofitable servant that Pastor Jenner
went on to address even more of the
bizarre almost ritualistic practices he
had been introducing to his sermons now
some of you have expressed concerns over
the new sacraments of you have even
called them sacrilege and yet have we
not prospered have these same naysayers
these same doubting Thomases not
profited from all good works the pastor
declared I have shown you how to heal
the sick with the Lord's Prayer and the
blood of an unbaptized child I've shown
you how to see your future in the
stemming entrails of a quivering Crow
I've shown you the path to Glory but I
cannot make you follow this path I can
only show it to you it is you and you
alone who must follow it who must rise
and shade your old sense shed your old
self the words immediately call to mind
the image of the cicadas insects that
discard their outer carapaces and emerge
Anew bugs that also burrow into the
ground and wait lying dormant under the
Earth for years at a time all before
they emerge rising up again so they can
spread it was becoming clear that Pastor
Jenner was certainly deviating further
and further from the church's normal
religious practices his bold and blatant
descriptions of what sounded like
ritualistic sacrifices were shocking
enough to hear speaking of using blood
and entrails to bring the town the
prosperity it sought but if that wasn't
bad enough the worst was still yet to
come contained within the third and
final recording unlike the previous
cassettes most of the sermon from June 7
1960 was almost completely
unintelligible and without any Visual
Evidence to go along with it it was hard
for the foundation to make out exactly
what was going on it began with another
quote from Matthew This Time chapter 28
verse 6 which made mention of the
resurrection of Jesus that he had risen
and that people should come and see
where the Lord lay not a metaphor my
friends Pastor Jenner explained before
urging his congregation to join in some
kind of formation stat followed mothers
behind their daughters fathers behind
their sons turn to face the uh the
recording became unintelligible again
after that point with only a few more
words being audible the pastor seemed to
have gathered the townsfolk of
Darrington presumably for some new form
of ritual he encouraged the town's
children to close their eyes and pray
before reminding the congregation that
God sacrificed the life of his only son
Jesus frighteningly it appeared that
Pastor General was implying the adults
of Darrington should do the same one of
the next fragments of his sermon that
could be deciphered declared lamb is
slaughtered to feed the lion the sun is
slaughtered to fade between more and
more noise interfering with the
recording Pastor Jenner could be heard
saying The Pact is complete this WOW
shall be our Paradise before he
encouraged his congregation or those who
were left to dig deep and wait then came
perhaps the most horrifying part to the
tape the remainder of the recording
lasted 30 minutes comprised of pure
static or the foundation agents
listening to it assumed at first that it
was just interference but for their
audio analysis seemed to suggest that
the long continuous mass of hissing
wasn't static at all it was The
chittering Sound of Insects like the
noise made by cicadas for a Time the
incident at Darrington left the
foundation baffled there seemed to be no
clear answer as to what had happened not
one of the town's residents were
anywhere to be found and on top of that
there were no bodies no remains of any
kind to speak of if they were dead there
would at least be some kind of trace and
then there were all the questions raised
by Pastor Bartholomew Jenner's strange
sermons why did he seem so focused on
enacting rituals did any of his methods
really benefit the town and why did he
place so much emphasis on cicadas of all
things answers were few and far between
although almost six decades after the
foundation discovered the desolate town
of Darrington a new development would
come to light to be more accurate it was
56 years later on the 11th of January
2017 a foundation agent named Daniel
Mitchell was patrolling the area that
had formerly been Darrington North
Carolina before the foundation had
demolished all traces of the Town by
this point the SCP Foundation had long
thought that they had figured out
exactly what scp-3089 was they had even
encountered it emerging in a number of
different forms in both 2007 and 2015.
however it was what Daniel Mitchell
happened across during the routine
monthly Patrol that revealed the
horrifying Truth at the outskirts of the
area where the town had once been a
series of sinkholes had opened up at
some point between the previous monthly
check and this one in early 2017 and if
you think that these sinkholes caused a
disturbance in the earth and uncovered
all the bodies of the former residents
of Darrington you'd be wrong it was Far
Far stranger the foundation conducted a
full-scale examination of the sinkholes
around the demolished North Carolinian
town and these weren't just a few
patches of loose ground that had sunk
through the Geological Survey the
foundation carried out quickly revealed
that these sinkholes led to an extensive
network of tunnels underground they
extended several hundred kilometers
outwards practically covering the entire
underside of where Darrington had been
the tunnels seemed far too big than any
other created by any natural means but
the entire network also appeared too
rudimentary too imperfect to have been
carved using any modern excavation
technology like a large drill plus if
any equipment like that had been on site
the foundation would have noticed as
they kept the area monitored it was
almost like something had been burrowing
through the ground only to eventually
crawl back up to the surface resulting
in the sinkholes what's more of the
foundation's geological tests suggested
that the network of tunnels was almost
four decades old that would have placed
the date of their creation about 10
years after The Disappearance of
everyone in Darrington naturally the
foundation immediately launched a
mission to explore more of the tunnels
before even completing a full sweep of
the underground space in its entirety
they had made another Discovery
contained within the tunnels was over a
whole ton of organic material that had
been mostly preserved without
decomposing too much the SCP Foundation
began Gathering samples for testing
fighting most of this material to be
severely desiccated dermis tissue that
is the dense layer of skin beneath the
epidermis and it had all been entirely
dried out but that wasn't all the
testing uncovered according to genetic
analysis the tissue had two distinct
types of DNA present the first being
easily identified as human genetic
material which made sense despite the
material lacking in moisture the dermis
tissue didn't match the skin of any
other mammal but then the there was the
other DNA present combined with the
expected human DNA was the presence of
something else that the foundation
researchers had quite some difficulty
finding a match for eventually they
determined that this genetic material
entangled with the human DNA belonged to
the sycadata Montana better known as The
New Forest cicada cicadas again cicada
DNA mixed with human DNA discovered in a
large network of underground tunnels all
beneath the same town where a pastor had
his congregation crushed cicada shells
in their left hands during one of his
sermons ten years before the sinkhole
incident the foundation was alerted to a
particular YouTube channel by the name
of Kai Sanchez positively rich on the
surface Kai was one of the many online
grifters preaching about how easy it was
to quickly achieve an obscene amount of
wealth by simply believing in yourself
usually if not always these types of
people were trying to scan Their
audience of loyal subscribers into
investing in some kind of illicit money
making scheme or any number of other
cons promising their followers easy
money that never came bakai Sanchez's
channel was slightly different so much
so the foundation had to contain his
entire audience deeming them to have
been affected by
scp-3089 the video that caught the
foundation's attention was an hour-long
upload from Kai entitled seven secrets
to ascend the ladder of prosperity there
was that word again Prosperity the same
thing Pastor Jenner had promised his
entire congregation in Darrington and
the similarities didn't end there in his
video much like the pastor during his
sermons Kai Sanchez encouraged his
audience to visualize their success in
order to achieve it he implied that the
human consciousness could impact reality
for example if his viewers just imagined
themselves having a bigger bank account
or looking more attractive then these
things would manifest themselves into
the real world one of Kai's Secret to
ascend the ladder of prosperity was as
follows visualize your ascendance
reimagine yourself as someone who can
reach the top of that ladder shed your
old identity tear it off throw it aside
like dead skin you won't need it not
where you're going the resemblance to
Pastor Jenner's sermons was uncanny
Kai's video even encouraged that his
audience leaves scraps out to lure
strike cats into their homes and then
once they had one to take a knife and
well you remember what happened in
Darrington but Kai Sanchez made sure to
specify remember to hold the knife with
your left hand another online community
was tagged by the foundation for similar
teachings this group of insular men were
trying to apply the same methodology
primarily to attract women however they
also reasoned it could be used to
improve their own financial status and
physical stature all done through
visualizing and believing that doing so
would make these things improve that
having faith would grant them Prosperity
this Disturbed Community even tried to
use bug Rattlers to emit frequencies to
Aid in attracting women contained within
these Rattlers were the preserved
remains of cicadas male cicadas have Tim
balls structures on their outer shell
that emit a loud hissing chittering
noise that they often use to find a mate
after spending so much time dormant
underground before burrowing up to the
surface and if you've been paying
attention you might be able to guess
exactly where this is going
scp-3089 is a phenomenon that occurs
within communities of people who are
seeking some form of prosperity whether
that community be a town a group of
like-minded people online or any other
group of collected individuals the
particular type of prosperity these
people are all seeking can be anything
from spiritual enlightenment to
financial success the SCP Foundation
does not yet quite understand exactly
how scp-3089 starts only that the
community is affected by it will attempt
to achieve their chosen material success
through the application of rituals like
visualizing what they hope to overcome
and Achieve and practicing sacrifices in
short these people have to believe these
acts will grant them what they want they
need to be willing to go far enough to
do unspeakable things they need to have
faith although what they don't realize
is some things can feed on that Faith
they can Harvest it before these
communities realize the terrible things
that they have done or who exactly has
tricked them into performing these
rituals they'll begin to undergo a
horrific transformation process known as
scp-3089-b it begins in the Chrysalis
Stage members of a community that have
been affected by scp-3089 Will
experienced a decline state of
metabolism now classified as an instance
of
scp-3089-a their brain activity heart
rate and body temperature will all begin
to lower over a period of between three
and six hours these people will then
suffer for a change to their epidermis
the outer layer of skin it starts to
harden until it does form a dense
brittle substance like a shell next
comes the second stage of
scp-3089-b metamorphosis internally
scp-3089-a individuals will develop a
number of tetramas a type of germ cell
tumor that can contain several different
types of tissue such as hair muscle and
bone during the next two or three weeks
these tumors will expand and dissolve
the person's soft tissue then there's
the final stage emergence an instance of
scp-3089-a will exit its Dorman state
that began in the initial stage once
they have awoken then something exits
the outer epidermal shell it will not
communicate some will retain remnants of
internal organs such as eyes or lungs
however these are vestigial no longer
serving any purpose the brain functions
deviate from any normal human patterns
having completed the process this thing
will attempt to burrow down into the
soil via any means at its disposal an
outer shell digging into the soil the
tunnels underneath Darrington the
genetic material uncovered below dermis
tissue with two types of DNA a mix of
human and cicada there is something out
there it is preying on people's Faith
their longing for Prosperity than when
these communities are presented with
someone who can take advantage of that
Faith Like Pastor Jenner or Kai Sanchez
they find themselves encouraged to push
their faith to its furthest limit and
then they are rewarded by becoming
something else something nightmarish the
question is when they wake up and crawl
back out from their tunnels leaving a
sinkhole in their wake where do these
cicada creatures go Russell's Back was
pressed against the wall his shuddering
hands ripping the fire ax the low
emergency lighting filling the corridor
indicated the lockdown was still in
effect although that was simultaneously
a blessing and a curse sure it meant
that thing couldn't get out hopefully
but it also meant that Russell was stuck
in the wing of the facility with it he
had no idea if anyone else was left he
hadn't seen what had happened to
Carpenter maybe it got him or perhaps he
had managed to give it the slip at the
last second there was no way of knowing
for sure it had all started so simply so
innocently and with such Noble
intentions if he had known it would lead
to all this madness Russell would have
never put his name down on the request
form the SCP Foundation had been working
on a way to neutralize or cure scp-610
for what felt like forever to one team
of scientists the infamously so-called
flesh that hates was a fascinating
organism it was a highly contagious
sarcic skin disease isolated entirely
within the small area of Siberia that on
its own wasn't enough to Peak the
interest of the research team led by Dr
Carpenter including his hand-picked star
researchers Russell and David along with
their assistant Clinton and Dr bottin an
expert on infectious diseases who had
recently joined their efforts to provide
his specialist knowledge what did
Captivate all of them however was what
scp-610 did when it infected a human
being the disease would trigger
aggressive and uncontrollable mutations
within its infected and could virtually
rewrite their entire physiology in a
heartbeat the flesh that hates was
capable of transforming a person's body
into a horrifying fleshing mass of Limbs
and matter that barely resemble the
human being anymore and in addition the
infected individuals would retain some
level of awareness attacking any
uninfected person with extreme hostility
there had long been chatter amongst some
other research teams studying
610 about devising a way to weaponize
the disease if they could somehow create
a variant that didn't turn people into
monsters or at least cause the fleshy
Abominations to die shortly after
mutation then the foundation or another
interested party could deploy the flesh
that hates as a biological weapon Dr
Carpenter had long abhorred the idea
instead searching for a way to
completely reverse the effects of an
scp-610 infection it may have been
idealistic perhaps even naive by some
standards but the rest of his team was
behind him in the pursuit of that Noble
goal although not one of them knew it
would soon cost them their lives hitting
speed bump after speed bump in the
research the team were beginning to lose
hope researcher David was the most
outspoken in how tired he was of seeing
the same results yelling in frustration
that the flesh could not be cured by
conventional means however it was that
Outburst that gave Russell the idea they
had tried treating scp-610 like a com
virus as if it was any other form of
disease largely thanks to Dr button's
input and granted that approach had
taught them a lot about the flesh's
ability to contaminate a subject from a
single cell but this infection was
anomalous through and through could the
solution to eradicating it for good lie
not in a medical cure but in another SCP
Russell brought this hypothesis to the
rest of the research team and each of
them had suggestions for other anomalies
they could potentially use to cure a
subject of the flesh that hates we could
get scp-049 to take a look at the
infected patient clenin suggested well
might work carpents are mused although
even if he cares someone he might also
kill them he has his whole deal about
ridding the world of the pestilence
could prove to be a problem there's
always 682 David said dryly have the
reptile eat up all the scp-610
infectives and voila problem solved a
real helpful David researcher Russell
retorted and what are we gonna do when
scp-682 adapts to the flesh you really
want an infected Immortal lizard on the
loose Gentlemen please Dr botton spoke
up we're forgetting one obvious option I
propose we submit a joint formal request
to use scp-914 for this experiment
unanimously the group all agreed that
this was the best course of action
scp-914 or the Clockworks was a giant
machine with two booths marked input and
output although the foundation still
couldn't fully comprehend exactly how as
cp914 seemed to take any object placed
within it and disassemble recreate
improve or destroy the item depending on
its current setting there was one issue
however a prior failed experiment where
in a d-class was placed in scp-914 had
led to some pretty disastrous
consequences as a result ever since no
organic matter was to be placed within
the Clockworks a rule that the teams
experiment with the flesh would breach
still they pressed on each of the five
researchers signing their request to
utilize scp-914 before it was submitted
to the foundation higher ups within
hours the request was denied but the
team was determined that scp-914 could
be the key to solving the foundation's
long-standing issue with scp-610 Dr
Carpenter repealed the decision
urging the higher-ups to reconsider he
argued that this flouting of the no
organic matter rule was necessary to
potentially rid the world of the flesh
that hates after a few days of
consideration the request was finally
Faithfully granted the team went to work
immediately requisitioning two test
subjects both of which had suffered
scp-610 infections and were horribly
mutated the pair of them were deemed a
potential Hazard to every member of
foundation staff on site and as a result
the entire wing of the facility where
the clock works with house had to be
evacuated for safety dressed in
biohazard suits to protect themselves
the researchers use used an electric
cattle prod to coax the first flesh
specimen into the input chamber of
scp-914 this was the test run they
wanted to see if the Clockworks would
actually be able to affect those
infected with scp-610 at all plus they
needed a Fail-Safe just in case
something went wrong and luckily the
machine had just the thing Russell asked
Clinton to set the Clockworks to rough
and with a click in War of its numerous
gears and Gyros
scp-914 came to life instantly the
infected test subject was completely
obliterated the setting had reduced it
to atoms disintegrating it on such a
microscopic level that there was nothing
left in the output chamber the second
infected creature seemed to bristle with
anger but didn't attack or become
aggressive as it too was plotted towards
the Clockworks next perhaps out of fear
that their Theory might be wrong the
team agreed to set scp-914 to its
one-to-one setting sure enough the
machine recreated another instance of a
specimen in fact did with the flesh that
hates replacing the previous one we all
know we're stalling researcher David
piped up let's do what we came here for
set the Clockworks to coarse nervously
receding a nod from Dr Carpenter Lennon
stepped forward to switch the dial on
scp-914 to the course setting this was
the primary reason the team had all
agreed to use the machine on a flesh
specimen this setting could disassemble
any item placed in the input Booth
separating it into its base components
botton had suggested the use of scp-914
based on the theory that if it worked
correctly the Clockworks could extract
the flesh that hates from its infected
host rendering them free of the disease
the machine made a colossal amount of
noise as clenan hurried back to a safe
distance with the others but as it was
powering up seconds from activating Dr
Carpenter noticed something the color
drained from his face as he saw it none
of the others had noticed from a
distance that the dial hadn't been set
to course instead it pointed to verify
fine the highest refinement setting 914
had what the hell have you done
Carpenter yelled at clennan before the
machine suddenly activated would step
free from the output Booth stunned the
researcher it was a man a seemingly
ordinary human who had presumably been
infected by scp-610 some time ago he
stepped nervously out of the machine
looking confused for a moment as a para
Foundation security guards cautiously
approached him we did it Russell said in
awe suddenly fleshy tendrils burst forth
from the man's arms latching on to the
approaching guards they screamed in
agony their bodies melting become a
bloody misshapen mass that stayed
attached to the humanoid creature at the
center it was like they became a part of
it the guards arms and legs forming
additional limbs as their forms were
reconstituted and repurposed as part of
a monster that was now crawling on its
six legs towards the research team in a
blind panic the group scrambled for the
entrance the head of the infected man's
splitting open down the middle opening
up into a wide snapping pair of Jaws
panting hard as he ran his breath
fogging up the clear faceplate of The
Biohazard suit Russell ran through the
door hearing someone close behind he
stopped for a moment looking back to see
the creature on the other side of the
door starting to spill through the door
frame like a liquid running faster
around a corner Russell came to another
halt in the common area a third security
guard following just before a thick
Steel security door came slamming down
sealing the creature on the other side
the other door didn't hold it what good
is that going to do researcher David
yelled more to the point Dr Carpenter
said turning and marching towards
Clinton he launched a furious punch at
the assistant knocking him to the floor
why did you set 914 to very fine clenin
the enraged doctor shouted you're the
one who Unleashed that Abomination you
maniac what Lennon replied fearfully
trembling I I didn't I swear I didn't it
said course I'm sure of it you expect us
to believe that was a mistake gentlemen
we need to focus on the situation at
hand the security officer interjected
regardless of who's responsible we need
to inform the foundation higher-ups
there's an emergency lockdown Russell
replied it would have triggered the
moment the scp-610 specimen got free
you've trapped us with a monster clenin
Dr Carpenter spat hold on researcher
David spoke up wasn't it botton's idea
to use 914 in the first place the common
area felt silent as everyone turned to
look at Dr Barton did you plan for this
doc David push Von chuckled need I
remind you my friends that we all agreed
to use the Clockworks did we not all of
our names are on the request he answered
besides accusing me David that's rather
Rich coming from you what's that
supposed to mean the researcher fired
back beckoning his finger botton
encouraged the rest of the team to
follow him across the common area to
where a row of lockers stood each door
bearing one of their names he gestured
to the one labeled David go on button
added shooting him a dirty look David
barch passed the disease expert and
opened his locker not one among the
group expected what would fall out it
was an old leather-bound book symbols
carved into the front cover instantly
thanks to the work studying scp-610 the
researchers all knew a text on sarcasism
when they saw one it had been long known
that the flesh that hates was often
described in text revered by sarkic
Colts who worshiped death Decay and
disease what the hell David Russell
exclaimed picking up the book and
examining it in disbelief you're a
sarkist carpenter asked the fury in his
voice already elevating no I'm not
recent David protested I've never seen
that before it was in your locker the
doctor yelled you're one of those
cannibal cultists this was your plan to
refine the flesh from your Twisted death
worshiping religion it certainly seems
that way button interjected after all
researcher David did seem frustrated at
our earlier results impatient even
you David pointed at the doctor you
planted this in my locker you're here a
sarkist clennan repeated in a nervous
stammer you made me turn the dial to
very fine you made that thing appear you
made me your accomplice anger tears
streamed on his face glennon's hand
reached for the security officer's gun
and went to draw it planning to shoot
David on the spot but as he went to pull
the weapon from the guard's holster it
wouldn't budge it was then that
assisting clenan stared in horror at his
hand his fingers had fused to the
guard's leg the officer gave a twisted
grin as his torso burst open tendrils of
Flesh latching on to clenin and
assimilating him just like it had done
before the flesh creature broke down its
victim's body making it a new part of
itself a grotesque mass of Limbs and
bloody matter littered with the
discarded faces of those it had infected
the research team looked at it terrified
their stomach's turning disgusted at the
growing growling abomination of bodies
fused to one another oh you're beautiful
Russell heard of voice whisper behind
him he turned to see Barton looking at
the scp-610 creature and smiling
researcher David was the closest and the
creature lunged at him pulling his leg
out from under him screaming in fear the
researcher fell onto the ground and was
dragged towards the flesh it pulled him
in his body stretching his skin tearing
and Bones snapping as he became part of
it a new set of Limbs added to the
monster Dr Carpenter went to try and
pull him free but it was already too
late but he stepped back knowing that if
he touched it he would be infected too
the sound of running caught Russell's
attention and he spotted botton making a
break for it grabbing Dr Carpenter by
the sleeve the researcher pulled him in
the same direction partly running away
from the flesh as it assimilated David
and partly Chasing The sarkic Saboteur
the pair of them quickly caught up to
botton leaning over himself and panting
breathlessly thank God you two made it
he wheezed after the run I can't believe
David could do this to unleash this
nightmare upon us Russell thought to
snap at him to scream how dare he keep
lying but Bottom's back was to him now
he'd never get a better chance there was
a cabinet on the corridor wall
containing a fire ax for emergencies as
carefully and quietly as he could
Russell fished the ax out of its case
while Spartan and carpenter were looking
away we should get the foundation to
lift the lockdown Vaughn was saying they
need to let us out and then oh he let
out a blood curdling scream mid-sentence
as the ax blade wounded him Russell
pulled it back standing over the doctor
as he fell to the floor in agony Russell
have you lost your mind Carpenter
exclaimed no doctor he's the cultist I
have no idea how he tricked Clinton but
that flesh creature exists because of
him the researcher answered from the
floor unable to move thanks to his
injury Dr botton began to laugh it took
me years to infiltrate the foundation so
much time waiting to gain access to that
blessed flesh he gluttoned and now
you've helped me to refine it to create
its ultimate would fall you want to kill
me go ahead Russell my life doesn't
matter for once that creature is free it
will bring about a new age of Flesh and
Grand consist iron will reward me for
the role I played in unleashing it David
was right Carpenter realized but
you you've planted that book on him to
throw us off doctor we need to think of
something researcher Russell interjected
ax still in hand nobody knows more about
the flesh that hates than us there must
be a way to kill that thing otherwise if
it gets out of this lockdown it could
spread to everyone in the foundation
what about fire that's been effective
against 610 infectives before right yes
yes but the doctor desperately tried to
think this new being we've created she
created Russell argued looking at the
grimacing wounded button we cannot deny
the role we've all played in this
researcher Carpenter argued and we have
no idea if it possesses the same
weaknesses as the flesh before its
refinement but we have to try sir the
researcher protested of course I agree
the sickening sound of a slithering
slick Mass was rapidly approaching still
laying on the floor in pain Dr botton
had been dragged to the middle of a
junction with Carpenter and Russell
hiding around either Corner suddenly
botton started hollering as the flesh
came into view practically calling it to
him oh look at you he exclaimed you're
better than I could have ever hoped for
looking down at him with the faces that
had collected the creature stabbed one
of its disgusting appendages through
botton drawing its body into its growing
form I am honored to give my life so
that the age of Flesh May begin the
doctor said weekly through the pain as
he was infected from around the corner
Carpenter had taken the sarkic text and
set its pages on fire with a cigarette
lighter turning to the creature he
hurled the massive burning paper at it
hoping it would be enough fire to spread
to the flesh while it was assimilating
bottom who they had left there as paint
the fiery book collided with the
monstrosity as Russell peeked around the
corner he saw the flesh retreating from
the Flames Bond's body now added to it
for a moment it seemed like the creature
was afraid of the fire but slowly it
drew nearer and nearer to the book with
ease it stamped down the Flames with
baughton's leg dowsing the fire and
suffering no damage to it at all
gripping the accent his hands Russell
went to charge the creature only to feel
something push him back Dr Carpenter had
stopped him run he yelled instantly
Russell turned and raced down the
corridor the sound of fleshy tentacles
whipping through the air he dared not
looked back just in case the monster was
right behind him eventually he reached
another corner and slammed his back
against it hand shuddering as he held
onto the fire ax he had no idea what had
happened to Carpenter maybe it got him
or perhaps he had managed to give it the
slip at the last second Russell came a
hush voice from around the corner one
the researcher recognized he turned to
see Dr Carpenter approaching him
sneaking like he was trying to avoid
being heard I think I'd managed to give
it the slip doctor whispered for a
second Russell backed up his hands
tightening around the ax handle this
might have looked like Dr Carpenter but
was it are you really you doctor he
asked of course I am Carpenter replied
you think that I'm not that monstrosity
Russell raised the ax defensively only
to notice the sadness in the doctor's
face unable to bring himself to swing
even to find out the researcher lowered
his weapon Carpenter looked grateful
come on come on let's get them to lift
this lockdown you said I'm sure an MTF
can step in and take care of our mistake
as the pair of them cautiously made
their way towards one of the locked
doors Dr Carpenter reached out a hand to
place it on Russell's shoulder even
before she was a fully fledged doctor
Kate Barker always had a Fascination for
the outdoors growing up being out among
nature felt like she was connected to
the wider world one part of a larger
hole she intuited from a very young age
that the Earth had a system in Place
full of millions if not billions of
parts that all work together in the
hopes of achieving Perfect Balance
humans animals and insects right down to
the germs that were so small they
couldn't be seen unless under a
microscope and then of course there were
the plants trees flowers and all manner
of other Flora that provided the world
with so much more than making it look
beautiful and it was so much so that a
young Kate wanted to devote her life to
helping maintain our beautiful little
blue and green planet and understand
every part of it the way she did that
changed as the years went on as a child
it was learning how trees take in carbon
dioxide and water then use the sun's
energy to feed themselves and produce
oxygen through a process known as
photosynthesis then in high school Kate
was writing and giving presentations on
the importance of protecting the
environment and conserving Wildlife
trying to convince her classmates to see
the world in the same way she did by the
time College rolled around that
protection took on a seemingly more
proactive form standing out on picket
lines in protest when the college
announced it would be chopping down its
nearby Woods to expand the campus
eventually she was made Dr Kate Barker
and awarded her PhD in botany and plant
science she thought that would be when
the real work began having climbed her
way up to achieving her degree was only
the first step the next would involve
working tirelessly to keep the world's
Greenery alive after all Kate had
studied for years learning about
anything and everything to do with plant
life through different functions and
structures how each species had evolved
and could be classified and how they all
formed part of the planet's ecosystem
unfortunately even for those with a
noblest of intentions the harsh
unforgiving laws of reality can tend to
get in the way in Kate's case that came
in the form of being snapped up for a
job at a genetic research company sure
on the one hand she did get to rely on
all the information she had learned on
her way to earning her PhD but on the
downside all Kate got to use her
knowledge for was receiving intending
two various plant samples getting asked
occasionally to run tests on said
samples was about the Pinnacle of
excitement in her job somehow despite
working with plants Dr Barker couldn't
help but feel further away from nature
than she had ever been that was until an
unusual specimen was brought to her
department for analysis something unlike
anything Kate had seen in all her years
of research and study although she
didn't know it at the time this unique
plant would bring Dr Barker Closer To
Nature in a way she could never have
imagined because it was a sample of
scp-306 of course at the time and even
after the plant's anomalous properties
began to take effect Kate was completely
unaware of this when it was first
brought to her lab it seemed like just
an ordinary fungus no one had been able
to successfully identify it however but
if anyone could Dr Kate Barker was
perhaps the best qualified person where
was it found she asked the lab
technician as he handed her the sample
secured in a sealed airtight container
pretty close to here apparently the lab
tech replied Louisiana swamps are always
full of mushrooms and stuff like this
right yes that's true there are quite a
few different fungi native to Louisiana
kid answered instinctively like her
brain was on autopilot she was more
focused on examining the sample in the
Box than the conversation thing is no
one knows what kind this is or dangerous
I heard a rumor the locals used to call
it frog rot but apparently that was an
older name for the technician added
garnering a little more than a Mumble of
agreement from the doctor of Botany Kate
placed the clear perspex container near
the window letting the natural light of
the outdoors give her a better look at
what was inside it was a portion of a
dead tree it sparked soggy and darkened
from the swamp water growing out of its
side was a cluster of the mysterious
fungus in question looking more like
pustules or assist a tumor growing out
of the Dead wood as if it had drained
the bigger plant of all of its life
Kate's next few hours were spent taking
samples of the fungus keeping her hands
and face covered as she scraped away
parts of it to examine under her
microscope there was little abnormal
about it on a cellular level nothing in
testing to suggest that the sample was
toxic or directly harmful all cake could
decipher about the plant was that it was
related to a certain genus of fungi
known as trichophyton which includes the
same parasitic varieties of fungus that
can cause athlete's foot ringworm and
similar infections in humans still
unable to fully identify this species
Kate decided to take a closer look at
how it was growing putting the container
behind a safety screen she opened it up
and began to pull apart the sodden tree
bark with her gloved hands there was
definitely some kind of mass underneath
the bark what Kate initially assumed to
be the wood of the tree that the fungus
had taken root to nothing could have
prepared her for how wrong she was as
the bark split apart and crumbled away
it revealed what was underneath a
cottontail Swamp Rabbit the fungi took
on even more of a tumor-like appearance
when Dr Barker saw that it was actually
growing out of the rabbit's back having
actually taken root within the poor
creature's body as much as the sight of
it was profoundly upsetting even a
little sickening the scientist and Kate
knew that this was all just part of
nature taking its course once she got
over the initial shock it was even a
little fascinating her Botanical
expertise was second to none and through
that knowledge she knew that more fungi
guy grew in damp conditions but she had
never seen any genus grow from a
biological matter of another organism
dead nor alive could this mystery
species grow in any biomass even in a
human being worried about that
possibility Kate Went to store the
scp-306 sample until further testing
could be conducted as she placed it back
in the container her hand nudged one of
the fungi's bulbs causing it to expel a
wisp of tiny spores not that she could
see them of course they were
microscopically small but as they
drifted through the air the spores were
drawn to Kate up and towards where she
was steadily breathing the minute the
spores slipped undetected into her
Airway Dr Barker immediately began
coughing feeling a disgusting earthy
Tang at the back of her throat she
couldn't stop spluttering instinctively
raising her hand to cover her mouth her
rubber gloves were still covering her
fingers coding in even more invisible
residue from the Fungus and now Kate was
unknowingly breathing in more excusing
herself from work the rest of the day Dr
Kate Barker went home feeling sicker and
sicker as every minute passed a fever
was rapidly climbing limbs were
shuddering and still she couldn't stop
coughing and spluttering as she tried to
expel a foul lingering Sensation that
refused to leave her throat but those
weren't even the worst symptoms two days
had come and gone since the incident at
the lab and Kate still hadn't returned
to her job how could she she felt awful
and looked far worse large lesions had
started appearing on her skin rapidly
turning into warrants just looking at
them made Kate's stomach turn and on a
few occasions poking at them and feeling
these alien lumps on her skin caused her
to vomit every night she would go to bed
her body rapidly switching from
swelterling hot then becoming cold
enough to cause Kate to shiver
uncontrollably at first it looked like
the lesions were clearing falling away
from her skin soon after they had fully
formed into warts but the fleeting bit
of hope that gave her was quickly wiped
away when new ones started to grow in
their place this didn't just feel like
the flu or any other type of sickness
for that matter it felt painful on the
deepest tiniest level during what little
Restless sleep she did get Kate kept
having nightmares about doctors looking
at ourselves under a microscope watching
them changing into something else it had
been over two weeks since she had first
been exposed to
scp-306's spores and still she hadn't
been well enough to get back to work
each time Kate had called the human
resources department to inform them that
she still wasn't any better they always
came out with the same advice drink
plenty of fluids try to eat and keep
your strength up Dr Barker hadn't
stopped eating or drinking albeit at a
very slightly reduced rate her appetite
had been sapped along with most of her
energy although she had noticed that she
dropped a significant amount of weight
in an alarmingly short amount of time
three weeks later Kate flicked on the
bathroom light and barely recognized
herself Not only was she no longer at a
healthy weight but her skin something
was very wrong
skin she had developed an abnormal
pigmentation a yellowish greenish shoe
almost like she had somehow developed
jaundice but to the touch it felt a
strange almost rubbery texture in fact
if she hadn't felt so sick Kate would
have noticed that her skin wasn't
absorbing water the way it was used to
either displaying the same type of
permeability as the skin of most
amphibians two months had gone past and
nobody at the research company had heard
a word from Kate she wasn't answering
her phone a few of them were asked to go
to her apartment to check on her but she
never came to the door either none of
them had any idea what had happened they
certainly didn't know about the changes
that her body had undergone and none of
them painlessly either the constant pain
Kate had been feeling had gradually
built and built until it felt like parts
of her body were twisting and contorting
against her will and an natural ways
with a grinding feeling of her bones
pulling each other as they shrank her
limbs were racked with unbearable Agony
at the same time her stomach had shrunk
to the point where she wasn't even able
to eat anymore the same reduction was
occurring to the rest of her organs too
heart liver lungs brain everything was
getting smaller shrinking organs
imprisoned within the skeleton that was
also decreasing in size then one morning
the pain had seemingly stopped after a
night spent screaming in sheer Agony
tears streaming down her face Kate woke
up on the floor of her apartment under a
pile of her clothes but as she awoke she
instantly noticed something everything
looked bigger the whole room towered
above her like she had been reduced down
to the size of something much smaller
than a human she tried opening her mouth
to say something anything but her lips
couldn't form words anymore her arms
felt strange too like their reach was
somehow much shorter the same with her
legs that were now under her body her
tiny rubbery skinned body
scp-306 had turned her into a frog it
took Kate almost an entire day to figure
out how to properly move around first
needing a long time to emotionally
process what had happened to her if she
had still been able to she would have
been sick and cried endlessly wailing on
the floor instead when she tried to make
any noise a tiny croak was all that
emanated from the back of her horse
throat but before she could find a way
to leave her apartment something else
found their way in from way down on the
floor the men in their white Hazard
suits looked colossal impossibly tall
Kate tried her best to dodge between the
thick soles of their heavy boots as they
came crashing down towards her from
above each one having enough force
behind it to crush her in an instant she
leaped out of the way of one descending
boot only to be caught mid-air in a
glass container as the lid screwed
tightly shut sealing her inside Kate was
lifted up and saw a patch of the Hazmat
uniform of the men that had come to take
her away a black circle with three
arrows pointing in towards its Center
and an outline surrounding it the
foundation put her in a glass tank with
11 other frogs each of them looking
almost identical to Kate all climbing
over each other fighting for their own
space in the tiny enclosure from the
moment she arrived Kate could see the
same thing in their gaze as they could
see in hers sadness unmistakable even in
those dark beady little eyes these were
people or at least they had been human
beings at some point but now anything on
the outside that had made them unique
their individuality had been taken away
and their minds had all been locked
inside the same frog-shaped body as Kate
now found herself in over the next few
months the foundation had their
scientists running a series of tests on
the frogs who are now all categorized
under the collective designation of
scp-306-1 even though she was unable to
speak Kate recognized their methodical
scientific process how they would test
one or two of the frogs at a time note
the results then change a variable and
repeat the test to see if there were any
changes it was the same process she used
to go through every time a new sample
arrived at her lab watching the
researchers reminded her of her old job
the life she'd worked so hard for and
was cruelly reminded that it was all
gone now nobody would ever know where
she went she'd never be able to go out
amongst nature in the way that she had
always loved Kate had long since figured
out the root cause of her transformation
a while after she had started to feel
sick she'd wonder if that strange fungus
had anything to do with it seeing all
the foundation scientists and guards in
their Hazmat gear only handling the
other frogs with thick rubber gloves
seemed to prove her Theory right and
suggested that she and her fellow
amphibians were still infectious still
she currently had no way of
communicating with the foundation
Personnel about what had caused her to
change although they seemed as if they
already knew most of the tests involved
the researchers putting Kate and the
other frogs into mazes or making them
solve puzzles or memorizing commands
naturally having once been human they
all picked it up quicker than the
researchers expected from their
perspective these frogs were displaying
an extremely advanced form of
intelligence gradually the testing
progressed and the foundation's
researchers began attempting to teach
the Frog specimens to read and write all
skills that they had already possessed
even if some of them needed some time to
learn how to hold a pen in their new
sticky fingers Kate herself was made to
complete an IQ test scoring 127 points
now that she had a way to communicate
with these scientists through writing
notes she and the other
scp-306-1s were asked to their names
that was the moment the foundation
realized what they were these weren't
just frogs but human beings were now
trapped in the bodies of frogs perhaps
inspired by this human to frog
transformation or possibly as some cruel
joke one of the foundation researchers
who went by the name Thompson brought
brought in a children's book and
presented it to the collection of
scp-306-1 specimens at first Kate
enjoyed the Simplicity of the stories
and it seemed her fellow frogs did as
well but gradually they all grew
depressed maybe one of the stories
featuring a prince being turned from a
frog back into human form while the 12
remaining specimens had yet to be
presented with a magical cure for their
condition or perhaps seeing something as
simple as a children's book reminded
some of the frogs of all they were still
to do in their old lives like starting
families and now they wouldn't get the
chance Kate and some of the other frogs
began writing notes to Thompson and
another of the researchers who had been
feeding them Phyllis they did their best
to be reasonable with the foundation but
also communicate how desperately they
wanted to be set free you have no right
to keep us here Kate wrote Under The
Towering star of Phyllis and Thompson
feeling for the first time in a long
while that she was actively doing
something to make a difference in nature
we need to be out in the world we need
to be free if she had more space on the
paper she would have tried to note down
suggestions of places the frogs could be
introduced where they wouldn't pose any
risk of disrupting the local ecosystem
the swamps of Louisiana where the
scp-306 fungus had been found were one
such idea that came to mind but much to
Dr Kate Barker's disappointment she and
her fellow frogs would only cause the
fungi's Infectious properties to spread
meaning they're pleased with the
foundation fell on deaf ears there was
no other choice nothing else they could
do they needed to break out as night
fell Kate organized the frogs gradually
writing out instructions for how they
were going to escape communicating with
them the same way she had with the
researchers only this time the others
listened even if they couldn't be human
again they didn't want to live the rest
of their short life spans being locked
up and tested forever Kate marked down
the time that Thompson and Phyllis
usually fed the frogs and Drew up a
detailed strategy if she could hide for
long enough under the others it might
make it seem like one of the specimens
was missing the next day researcher
Thompson and researcher Phyllis arrived
to feed the scp-306-1 specimens
accompanied by security guards as always
while her colleague went to collect the
feed for her to administer Phyllis did a
count of the frogs 11. she counted again
only to get the same result there was
one missing as she leaned closer to the
tank Kate trusted her fellow amphibians
above to follow the plan in a Flash the
massive frogs had leaps from their
containment and pinned Phyllis to the
ground this one the room erupted into
chaos people turned frogs leaping in all
directions as they scattered and made a
Mad Dash for Freedom a gunshot rang out
from one of the security guards trying
to subdue the creatures only for the
Stray shot to catch researcher Thompson
in the neck killing him leading the
charge on her tiny rubbery legs Kate
jumped closer and closer to the exit it
was so close if she could just get far
enough away she might finally be free to
get back to Nature the tiny carnivorous
snow women are Relentless sharp fangs
dripping with blood as they crawl on
mass towards the mobile task force
opening fire on them with their assault
rifles who would have guessed that a
mere hour or two earlier a young boy was
joyfully playing around in the snow here
how had things gone from Frosty to
freaky so fast let's rewind the clock
there was a chill in the air that
lingering biting coal that would gnaw in
your Exposed Skin if you dare to step
outside in anything less than a thick
warm coat for protection the ground was
still coated in a heavy snowfall a
holdover from Christmas just passed
whether that had refused to let up well
into the early days of the New Year
everyone reaches an age where the
cynicism of Life the weight of
expectations that keep you anchored in
the real world they all coalesce to rob
you of the childlike wonder of the snow
as you get older the snow loses its
novelty it becomes a source of
inconvenience something that you need to
you shovel off the driveway to take your
car out whereas turn the clock back to
Youth and it's like a tiny Miracle It
Coats your whole world in a clean
blanket of freezing Frost turning the
ordinary into a Wonderland Robert and
Michaela Anderson were glad that their
son Michael was still at an age where he
could enjoy the snow after all Michaela
getting to take her son out in a sled or
seeing him hurling snowballs at Robert
was able to provide them with a little
bit of warmth during the freezing cold
snowier months in Missouri optimism was
never enough to melt the snow however
and maybe that's what drew in those
creatures the snowmen it was early 2019
not even a full two weeks into the Year
by now Michael had gotten used to the
fact that after Christmas and New Year's
Day a begrudging return to school would
soon follow as much as it clearly
brought down his mood nothing lifted his
spirits like still getting to be out in
this snow and after a long day of
helping his mom take down the tinsel and
pack up the lights while his dad
disposed of the tree Michael was itching
to go outside please Mom he begged as a
box of decorations was placed back in
the attic his hands clasped together in
a pleading gesture please please please
just five minutes I will go further than
the front yard Michaela sighed partly
from exhaustion but a smile crept onto
her face it was hard not to find her
son's love for the snow endearing all
right but only for five minutes she
insisted firmly and I want to see gloves
hat and a scarf not just a coat Mister
with the speed and excitement that she
and her husband had long since lost she
watched Michael race off to gather his
warmest winter coat remember when we
were like that Robert heave decides he
appeared from chopping up that dried out
dehydrated remains of the Christmas tree
no do you Michaela replied with a light
chuckle before long Michael had donned
his gloves and coat almost a size too
big egg his scarf was almost wrapping up
his entire head save for the little
bobble head that poked out at the top
Robert opened up the front door and his
son stepped out into a world that had
been whitewashed with clear cold snow
given that the Andersons lived on a
small Street in Grain Valley there
weren't many other people around
especially not with another flurry of
snowfall moving closer in the clouds up
above but it wasn't the next snowfall
that the residents of Grain Valley
Missouri should have been worrying about
it was the previous one the one that had
already fallen and what was now hiding
among the snow in the Anderson family's
front yard having few other kids his own
age to play with and not being allowed
to venture too far from the front porch
Michael was content to spend his
precious time Outdoors making snow
angels or practicing throwing snowballs
he had long been trying to get one to
clear the roof of the small house he and
his parents shared leaving a few
scattered patches of snow embedded on
the room shingles a few meters from the
front door stood a snowman granted that
was hardly a rare sight at this time of
year especially in the cold weather but
what was so unusual about it was that
Michael hadn't remembered making a
snowman recently his parents had him let
him out in the snow on his own since the
start of the New Year given how badly
the downfall and icy winds had been for
the first week of January sure somebody
else could have made it taking a pause
as they passed by the Anderson's front
yard although not Michael Nor either of
his parents had spotted anyone doing
that the Snowman itself was featureless
the white of its ice cold body smeared
with mud and Dead Leaves debris that had
been packed in with the snow used in its
crude construction it was featureless
too whoever had made it hadn't gone to
the effort of giving it a phase nor
draped an old scarf over it or given it
a hat it just stood there but not like
any other snowman there was nothing
welcoming about it in fact it was
fittingly
given how far away it stood it was
almost as if it was watching the house
curiously Michael began to approach the
Snowman being only nine years old his
imagination was immediately running with
the possibility that this snow and mulch
construct could be alive much akin to
the likes of Frosty the Snowman little
did young Michael Anderson know that he
wasn't far away from the truth although
this particular snowman wasn't quite the
happy Jolly soul from the much covered
holiday song he hadn't got that much
closer to the Snowman when he heard
something move nearer to where he stood
there was the rustle of leaves and the
Snapping of small Twigs coming up from a
bush next to him Michael couldn't see
what it was but it was far too low to
the ground and too close to the house
for it to be a bird maybe a possum or
raccoon had gotten trapped in the thin
branches and was now scrambling to try
and free itself diverting from
approaching the Snowman he walked closer
to the plant as he did the rustling gun
outer more frantic almost hungry there
wasn't just one creature lurking out of
sight beneath the leaves but lots of
some things Robert and Michaela had been
sitting indoors watching the TV when
they heard a spine chilling scream
coming from outside instantly they were
both up on their feet racing toward the
front door Robert threw it open and
Michael dashed inside in floods of
fearful tears what happened sweetie
Michaela asked concerned brushing
snowflakes from her son's coat are you
okay did you slip through crying and
sniffling shaking uncontrollably with
how afraid he was Michael couldn't find
the words to answer instead he pointed
through the still open door directly at
the Snowman still standing at the edge
of the front yard how long has that been
there Robert wondered aloud taking a
single step outside don't dad Michael
screamed but it was already too late
something small and Speedy had leaped
out of the snow in the front yard and
latched onto Robert's leg he howled as
he felt searing pain bitten by rows of
tiny pointed teeth as sharp as needles
and as bitterly cold as ice stumbling
back Robert Anderson fell over and
landed on the floor in the front hallway
inadvertently carrying whatever had
attacked him into his home both Michaela
and Michael screamed in fear as the tiny
creature clawed its way up Robert's leg
while he swatted at it frantically
trying to brush it away before it could
get closer with a blind swipe of his
hand he knocked the creature to the
floor and clambered to his feet arms
outstretched keeping his wife and son
behind him while staring in disbelief at
what had bitten him it was barely more
than half a meter tall a tiny white
snowman bulbous bloodied eyes bulged
from its head much like those of an
insect directly between the eyes was a
hole a mouth not unlike a lamprey lined
with rows of sharp teeth that all
pointed inwards it reared up and lunged
toward the Anderson family in the
display of aggression that caused all
three of them to jump rarely backing
away from the snow creature it was then
that Robert and Michaela noticed what it
frighten their son so much out of the
corner of their eye they both
simultaneously cut the sight of the open
front door and the yard Beyond wriggling
through the snow shifting as they moved
or even more of the creatures slithering
towards the house like piranhas catching
the scent of blood in the water and
standing ominously just beyond the
driveway was the Snowman as if it was
the General commanding its troops to
storm the house the Andersons raced
upstairs as the swarm of snow creatures
came spilling into the house crawling
from the yard onto the floor and piling
on top of each other like ants to climb
the stairs naturally Michaela's first
instinct as well as protecting her son
was to call the police while Robert Held
the door to the bedroom shut Michaela
held Michael close and pleaded with the
local grain Valley Police Department to
come and help them although they only
seemed to take the call seriously when
Michael started screaming again one of
the snow creatures had pushed its way
under the door frame and was sneaking
its way towards Robert to attack him
leaving a trail of of water behind it
stepping back and Thinking Fast Robert
grabbed a hair dryer and switched it on
full blast the Sudden Rush of
electrically heated air caused the
toothy snow creature to retreat into a
corner refusing to let up Robert got
closer and kept the hairdryer trained on
it eventually causing the creature to
melt until little more was left than a
damp puddle but the victory was
momentary there were still more of them
crawling up the stairs after the
Andersons with their sharp teeth they
were gnawing at the wood of the bedroom
door trying to force their way inside
fortunately for Robert Michaela and
their son Michael they wouldn't be able
to recall the horrific events of January
12 2019 for much longer by the time the
local police arrived it had become clear
to the officers responding that they
were well out of their depth especially
when one of them was injured suffering a
bite from a snow creature that was what
led the SCP Foundation being called in
and within 15 minutes they had
dispatched mobile task force operatives
to secure the anomaly being some of the
foundation most highly trained agents it
didn't take long for the MTF to
neutralize the carnivorous snow
creatures however they quickly realized
that the mysterious snowmen that had
seemingly spawned the Swarm could not be
melted by any conventional means nor
would it deteriorate naturally on its
own a cover story was issued that
Michael had suffered an accident and
fallen down an open pothole that had
become obscured by heavy snowfall as a
result police officers were dispatched
to help him although the injury
sustained by one officer due to a bite
from a snow creature was never explained
following this the Anderson family was
administered amnestics meaning they
quickly forgot about the whole
terrifying ordeal maybe it was for the
best however young Michael seemed
irreparably changed he never went out to
enjoy the snow again repeatedly
suffering from nightmares about the cold
meanwhile the anomalous snowman was
recovered and thus designated as
scp-4230 immediately the SCP Foundation
did as their organization does best and
commenced testing with a human subject
no less they quickly discovered that
scp-4230 seemed to generate a sort of
field around itself that could trigger a
distinctive physiological change in any
human being or animal that came within
six meters of the Snowman this process
became known under the designation of
scp-4230-1 it appeared that Michael
Anderson had managed to unknowingly
escape this fate purely by not getting
too close to scp-4230 staying just far
enough away so as not to trigger
scp-4230-1 the foundation placed
d-19375 a member of their d-class
personnel within this six meter radius
of the Snowman and observed the gradual
changes he underwent over the following
week for simplicity's sake will refer to
d-19375 as frost a rather fitting
moniker and you'll soon see why within a
day of exposure to the Snowman Frost
complained to a senior researcher that
he felt a lot colder than usual a
although he exhibited no other
observable symptoms beyond the coughing
and sniffling of a common cold by the
following day Frost was far worse for
wear appearing to have lost significant
body mass to the point where he'd
appeared to have been malnourished his
cold-like symptoms had continued
accompanied by disorienting dizziness
and as if all that wasn't bad enough his
skin tone had seemingly lost its natural
pigment reduced to an unnaturally pale
shade as white as snow day three saw
Frost's body continue to change rapidly
at an alarming rate he was internally
producing an unknown chemical that
looked to be responsible for enacting
certain alterations namely the
dissolving of his femur and fibula the
cold and dizziness were also now made
all the worst by the addition of pain to
the man's lower body Frost even reported
to Foundation researchers studying him
that every movement he was able to make
caused him to suffer extreme levels of
physical pain but yet rather than
attempt to cure his condition the
foundation apathy aesthetically observed
noting down the process of
scp-4230-1 within five days of exposure
to scp-4230 naturally occurring
substances within Frost's body had
traveled downwards and solidified this
was followed by the most shocking stage
of the scp-4230-1 process so far and one
that made the foundation realize that
these weren't just changes it was a
transformation when day 5 saw Frost's
skeleton physically reshaping itself his
head becoming a sphere and his arms
extending outwards like brittle Twigs it
soon became clear what was happening to
him he was turning into a snowman
rendered immobile and blind a week after
scp-4230-1 began to take effect Frost
had started to secrete an unknown
substance this liquid lowered his body
temperature freezing almost instantly
and turning his skin into an icy white
Mass worryingly similar to snow sure
enough on the Eighth Day the extent of
the scp-4230-1 process was made evident
Frost had already perished his body now
looking identical to a plain featureless
Snowman no eyes or face just a blank
cold slate but underneath the outer
layer of snow Frost's bones and the rest
of his organs were still contained
inside from the outside though he wasn't
even human anymore just an instance of
what became known as
scp-4230-a however being turned into
another Snowman by close proximity to
scp-4230 wasn't even the worst part by
now you might be wondering what were
those snow creatures that attacked the
Andersons you'd be forgiven for thinking
that perhaps these were rodents or other
wild animals affected by scp-4230-1
after all testing has shown that the
process doesn't just alter human
physiology but these carnivorous needle
tooth creatures are known as
scp-4230-bs and they are nasty little
Critters to say the least when a person
or animal is turned into a snowman
during
scp-4230-1 becoming one of these
instances is far from the full extent of
the transformation the test the
foundation conducted on Frost and
presumably on numerous other d-class
personnel as well led to them
discovering the further alterations made
when someone becomes an
scp-4230-a instance their freezing snow
encased bodies become hosts for white
spherical eggs after a subject like
frost becomes an
scp-4230-a snowman these eggs will hatch
within 72 hours producing up to 19
instances of
scp-4230-b creatures the foundation was
quick to examine these bizarre snow
spawn Gathering up as many as they could
for testing they found that instances of
scp-4230-b matured to adulthood
remarkably quickly reaching adulthood in
15 seconds destroying the eggs
containing creatures seem to be an
effective way of preventing swarms of
scp-4230-bs from getting loose although
the Snowman each egg came from would
also have to be destroyed to achieve
this result also the lifespans of the
smaller snow creatures only lasted for a
total of 24 hours and they would melt
away after a full day of life regardless
of the surrounding temperature
scp-4230-b seem uninterested in food
that was presented to them specifically
one test involved giving a snow creature
a head of lettuce and a watermelon the
creature regarded the fruit and
vegetables with little interest even
refusing to eat either despite prompts
from the researchers this painted the
scp-4230-bs as exclusive carnivores
which explained why they attacked the
Anderson family they were trying to eat
them hunting the Andersons as a pack
further testing into
scp-4230-bs revealed they had a weakness
to heat above a temperature of 40
degrees Fahrenheit during another test a
d-class was sent into a cell with 10 of
the carnivorous snow creatures armed
only with a simple lighter an emergency
flare and one gallon of gasoline
immediately all 10 of the
scp-4230-bs crawled toward the man
hungry and determined him to be a new
source of food that is until they
noticed the lighter he was carrying the
d-class frantically clicked the spark
wheel until the flame danced from the
lighter causing seven of the creatures
to back away from the heat Source
cautiously the d-class was able to kill
the remaining three instances in
self-defense causing them to melt with
little effort he was Far luckier than
the subject of the next test would be
another d-class was placed in a holding
cell with three of the snow creatures
and much like before they instantly
acknowledged his presence and began
approaching him however the foundation
had sent this member of d-class in
completely unarmed without even so much
as a match to defend himself the
carnivorous beasts made short work of
their helpless victim feeding on what
was left the foundation was able to
dispatch instances of
scp-4230-b with relative ease even
without waiting for them to Simply melt
after a day the use of flamethrowers or
drawing them into warmer areas seemed
effective enough at destroying the small
snowman that hatched out of
scp-4230-a bodies however some bright
spark at the foundation decided to test
what would happen if the opposite
element was used against
scp-4230-b creatures were they
vulnerable to the snow despite being
made from a snow-like substance
themselves another test was conducted to
answer this which involved a small
snowball being thrown at one of the
scp-4230-bs the result of that incident
has been entirely expunged from the
foundation's archives but it's a safe
guess to ask why evidently when attacked
using snow or ice
scp-4230-bs are seemingly able to adapt
in some way that is determined to their
attacker do they add snow to their mass
or become even more aggressive it's hard
to say given the redactions but the
result of that final test were deemed so
catastrophic that the foundation banned
any further testing that involved
scp-4230-bs as for where
scp-4231st came from the foundation is
still baffled the first reported
incident involving the Killer Snowman
and the carnivorous creatures It
produced came when the Andersons found
themselves Under Siege by hungry
scp-4230-bs maybe the Snowman is just a
freak of nature or the result of an
unknown pathogen or microorganism
carried in a snowstorm one fateful night
or perhaps
scp-4230 is something far far more
vicious whatever the case we would
recommend waiting for the sun to come
back out and the snow to melt just to be
safe the creature let out an
unmistakable squeal of Rage as stimulus
y835 took effect Dr Christensen pressed
his face up against the glass eager to
see the results it had work this time it
simply had to he was certain that this
attempt would make all the other
failures worth it and he'd once again
prove the foundation's faith in him to
be well placed
scp-5683 shrieked a loud insect-like
sound that would have normally made the
blood run cold of anyone that heard it
but to Dr Christensen it was like music
a monster's dying Fanfare to mark his
success soon he'd be the researcher who
neutralized not one but two tenacious
highly adaptable anomalies the senior
researcher could feel his heart racing
as the deadly giant spider started to
Twitch then burst into two identical
entities the pair of arachnid anomalies
had reacted much like the results of the
tissue sample tests conducted earlier
dividing into two separate organisms
Christensen held his breath the tissue
samples had destroyed each other
attacking and injecting the other with
lethal doses of Venom surely he reads
duplicating
scp-5683 into 2 would have the same
result his heart sank as he watched one
of the spider creatures the duplicate
perish almost immediately as it often
did when presented with human prey as CP
5683 attacked using its mandibles and
impaled its copy with its front legs to
pin it in place the Clone had bitten
back with Dr Christensen already knowing
that would have granted
scp-5683 an immunity to its own Venom
its powers of adaptation were fiercely
frustratingly efficient and nothing
demonstrated this more than the intense
reaction from the man tasked with
destroying it Dr Christensen hurled the
nearest object a coffee mug had a glass
window of the observation room
overlooking the test chamber he pounded
his fist against the glass hardly with
the required Force to cause damage but
enough to send pain shooting down
christensen's wrist which then nestled
in his forearm a reminder that the
experiment like the others had failed
why can't I destroy you he muttered
through clenched teeth looking with
hatred at the enormous spider in the
chamber below the directive had reached
him the day immediately after New Year's
Day 2020 and straight from a member of
the o5 council no less their message
expressed how impressed the council was
with Dr christensen's success with the
Doomsday Clock project and out favorably
his name had been mentioned in Council
meetings this voted well for the
ambitious Foundation doctor he'd been
hoping to snag the director position at
site-04 now that director Bray had
retired but there was one more test from
the o5 council they wanted Dr
Christensen to use the knowledge
garnered during his previous success to
solve the
scp-5683 problem if he could
successfully complete that assignment it
would be his ticket to being promoted
with the comfy role of site director and
all its perks in mind Dr Christensen
accepted the assignment from the council
to deal with
scp-5683
scp-5683 was quite the Beast not an
anomaly for those with intense
Arachnophobia the huge spider-like
organism was extremely hostile towards
humans and had to be kept in a constant
state of medical sedation otherwise it
would relentlessly attempt to breach
containment and Slaughter any and all
Personnel in its path what had made
scp-5683 such a problem for the
foundation was the creature's ability to
rapidly regenerate damage as well as
modify its own body in reaction to
threats much like a certain particularly
hard to destroy reptile The spider-like
Entity could adapt itself to become more
resistant to any danger posed to it and
of course this meant that the foundation
needed this dangerous creature
eradicated the frequent containment
breaches and sheer number of casualties
caused by the arachnid anomaly were
significant enough to cause an
increasing drain on the SCP foundation's
resources so with the termination order
coming from the very top the o5 council
themselves Dr Christensen was tasked
with overseeing the neutralization of
scp-5683 during an initial deliberation
Dr Christensen met with researcher miles
and Hall Junior researcher Silva and
security Chief at a to discuss earlier
attempts to terminate
scp-5683 the new head of the termination
project was perturbed to learn that the
research team had little in the way of
useful information to offer beyond what
the foundation already knew about the
creature but Christensen decided some
basic stress testing would at least be a
start after a successful tissue sample
test wherein some of
scp-5683's genetic material was
incinerated Dr Christensen tried to
Simply destroy the spider with fire an
understandable response to say the least
however exposing scp-5683 to
temperatures of 850 degrees Celsius for
just 30 seconds didn't quite yield the
easy Victory he had hoped for the
arachnid thrashed about and screeched in
reaction to the heat only to rapidly
develop a form of armor plating covering
its entire body the armor was comprised
of an unknown unidentifiable substance
but it was enough to prevent
scp-5683 from combusting reconvening
with the rest of the team Dr Christensen
hid his pride assuring everyone he was
just trying to establish a baseline
during the previous test of course he
hadn't believed that terminating
scp-5683 with fire would be a success or
so he claimed hiding how much he'd
longed for an easy solution so he could
snatch up the vacant site-04 director
position but to ensure the others
Christensen explained that he'd
requisition some anomalous materials for
from the o5 council that they'd be using
in their next termination attempts
nothing that was anomalous enough to
require containment but toxic enough
that they presented a few options for
destroying
scp-5683 uh just for logging purposes
sir may I inquire about the specific
substances we're shipping in junior
researcher Sylvia had asked of course
why 220 y835 and y43 Dr Christensen
quickly recounted them all from memory
I'm told they should be arriving within
the week I expect each would be enough
to do the job but it's best to hedge our
bets this spider doesn't compare to the
lizard I'll tell you that Junior
researcher Silva seemed to take an
interest in what Dr Christensen had just
alluded to his previous work with the
lizard he probed further about it and
Christensen gave a solemn response the
aspiring Foundation doctor recalled an
incident from a few years earlier during
his experimentation with scp-682 some of
the methods Dr Christensen had opted to
employ in an attempt to destroy the hard
to destroy reptile had led to a severe
Containment Breach when describing it he
used the word unpleasant perhaps out of
guilt at how many personnel had lost
their lives due to his actions brushing
the topic aside he assured the team to
get on with testing the new anomalous
stimuli on
scp-5683 stimulus y220 initially showed
some promise during a tissue sample test
it successfully converted part of
scp-5683 into glass which then violently
exploded leaving nothing behind but
attempts to use it to neutralize the
creature itself quickly quash those
promising results within nine seconds of
being exposed to stimulus y220
scp-5683's body rapidly turned to glass
around 80 percent of its arachnid Mass
proceeded to explode shattering in all
directions sending clear shards
showering over the testing chamber as he
watched Dr Christensen allowed himself
to believe that this was mission
accomplished that he'd successfully
terminated
scp-5683 but his celebration was
premature the spider quickly began
reconstituting itself its body
regenerating within the space of 30
seconds after testing with both stimuli
y220 and y835 Dr christensen's
frustration seemed to be increasing with
each failed attempt the newest promotion
was Within Reach and as far as he could
remember he'd done good work with
damaging scp-682 why should eradicating
this anomalous spider be any different
however it was a test with stimulus y436
that enraged the ambitious doctor
expecting the anomalous stimulant to
turn
scp-5683 into a fine Mist Christensen
watched as the creature's body vanished
literally vaporizing changing states of
matter to little more than water in the
air suddenly every light in the facility
powered off plunging the testing chamber
into darkness when the lights came back
on scp-56 83 was standing on all eight
legs right where it had been missed only
three seconds earlier the research team
had gathered for another mediation and
Dr christensen's anger still hadn't
subsided he kicked a chair to emphasize
his frustration alarming Junior
researcher Silva who urged him to calm
down after eventually cooling his temper
Christensen made an announcement that
caused even greater concern to spread
amongst the team I'm requisitioning why
910 researcher halls and researcher
miles subjected trying to get Dr
Christensen to realize that the course
of this action was excessive Overkill
even the Christensen disregarded them
standing by his latest method for
terminating
scp-5683 the global occult Coalition had
previously used y910 to poison Gods he
felt sure that it would work on one
anomalous giant spider his time was
running short Dr Christensen was aware
that any day now the o5 council would be
appointing a replacement Direct of
site-04 and he wanted that promotion and
he didn't seem to care what Corners he
cut and what risks he took to get there
even if it meant endangering his
research Personnel Dr Christensen
declared that in order to save time it
would be bypassing tissue samples to
test for termination attempts the longer
it took to terminate the anomalous
arachnid the more his window of
opportunity closed and the further the
director position slipped from his
fingertips accepting full responsibility
for The Reckless decision and anything
that might go wrong Dr Christensen
wanted to use stimulus y910 directly on
scp-5683 he urged the research team to
make the necessary preparations unaware
of what his decision would lead to and
the chaos it had already caused the test
was catastrophic so much so that it
caused a Containment Breach with
scp-5683 loose and scuttling about the
facility on its multiple legs Dr Chris
and Junior researcher Silva were forced
to rush to the secure bunker on site for
safety Christensen was in the state of
panic until he noticed something and not
for the first time either he'd been
detecting a foul smell whenever he'd
conducted the meetings to discuss
termination options but the other
members of the research team had quickly
explained it was nothing more than
repeated accidents in the cafeteria but
here was the stench again worse than
ever yet Junior researcher Silva brushed
it off again stating that
scp-5683 must have gotten into the
facility's reactor the junior researcher
quickly became inconsolable stating that
the whole situation was his fault Dr
Christensen interjected demanding to
know how it was and what Silva had done
to cause this situation he replied that
it was his duty to oppose ill-advised
actions and when Christensen had
declared his intention to use y910 the
Junior researcher hadn't opposed him
Shifting the blame from himself onto his
subordin Dr Christensen chastised Silva
over how many personnel had died because
of the junior researchers refusal to do
his job ignoring that it was
christensen's own Ambitions that had led
to the current chaos refusing to be made
a scapegoat Dr Christensen vowed to pin
the full culpability for
scp-5683's Containment Breach onto
Junior researcher Silva saying he'd tell
the o5 council the so-called truth about
what had happened but Silva pointed out
that there wasn't much of a likelihood
that the bunker would survive the
reactor overloading he urged the
ambitious Foundation doctor to admit
some responsibility of his own for what
had happened but Christensen refused
suddenly there came a thunderous banging
at the bunker door a debilitating Pang
of fear struck Dr Christensen causing
him to scream and Retreat from the
entrance yelling no and please as if he
was pleading with the universe itself to
spare him from the spider Junior
researcher Silva walked over to the
bunker door just as strong erected legs
tore the heavy steel bulkhead off its
hinges like it was made of little more
than wet paper there was
scp-5683 the enormous spidering Into the
Bunker screeching all the while Silva
had put himself between
scp-5683 and the ambitious Foundation
doctor whose hunger for a promotion had
led to all this Carnage the junior
researcher announced his Noble intention
to sacrifice himself occupying the
creature while urging Christensen to run
the doctor shoved Silva towards the
spider and prepared to run then all of a
sudden
scp-5683 vanished Junior researcher
Silva told Dr Christensen he was
disappointed before researcher miles
researcher Hall and security Chief Ade
all entered the bunker through the torn
open hole where the door had been
Christensen questioned where
scp-5683 had gone to which Silva
explained there was little reason to
keep a dummy around once it had served
its purpose as substitute you mentioned
you worked with a lizard sir the junior
researcher recounted that there was a
Containment Breach if you don't terribly
mind me asking how did you escape that
situation it seemed quite lethal didn't
it afraid and Confused Dr Christensen
asked where he was Hall and Miles urged
him not to ask questions he already knew
the answer to Silva explained who they
all were a jury specifically Dr
christensen's jury and according to them
the ambitious doctor had disgraced
himself again Christensen had been there
for a long time a considerably long time
reliving the same events over and over
again with scp-5683 acting as a
substitute for scp-682 it was the same
situation he'd made the same decisions
the same mistakes and it had cost lives
now Dr Christensen was trapped in an
endless Loop Penance for the casualties
that had occurred at his hands all in
the pursuit of his own selfish personal
gain he asked the jury how long he'd be
stuck there a question Silva responded
to with until you take responsibility
sir immediately Dr Christensen tried to
admit that this all had been his fault
but he didn't mean it not really he
hadn't accepted blame he just wanted a
quick and easy way out of the loop and
the jury of his deceased Personnel knew
it Christensen ran for the door in the
hopes of escaping his fate futile as his
chances were a black iron chain appeared
from around the corner and wrapped
itself around the over-ambitious
doctor's throat ignorant of his pleas
for forgiveness saying he was sorry
wouldn't bring back the people who died
in service of his aspirations to
becoming a site director the chain drag
Dr Christensen through the facility at
such a speed that he collided with every
wall and every corner as he turned Sharp
being pulled along the floor but that
and the walls quickly crumbled away
revealing a sight that made Dr
Christensen start screaming that it
wasn't his fault and he never really
stopped What followed involved a great
deal of blood and fire once it was over
it left behind the same awful stench the
doctor had smelt before and he'd soon be
smelling it again too as the cycle
repeated itself the directive had come
straight from a member of the o5 council
they were impressed with Dr Christensen
and the ambitious Foundation doctor had
been hoping to snag a director position
at site-04 but there was one final test
for Dr Christensen to solve the
scp-5683 problem now check out
scp-5000y the full story compilation and
scp-3023 and then it decided to be an
angry spider for more